[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous on est en
direct sur brut toutes les candidates et
candidats à la présidentielle sont venus
ici chez brut pour répondre à vos
questions vos préoccupations et ce soir
c'est au tour du président de la
République qui est aussi candidat à sa
propre élection de le faire bonsoir
Emmanuel Macron bonsoir pour
m'accompagner je suis avec Thomas
legarov bonsoir Thomas alors avec moi on
va confronter le président très
nombreuses questions que nous avons
reçues mais tout d'abord je te laisse
ouvrir avec la première question bonsoir
Emmanuel Macron bonsoir beaucoup de
questions qui vont nous permettre
d'aborder une série de thématique on va
parler d'écologie on va parler de santé
notamment de santé mentale et chez les
jeunes en particulier on va voir les
pouvoirs d'achat mais aussi d'identité
d'écoles questions internationale aussi
autour évidemment de la guerre en
Ukraine bref pas mal de choses à voir
sur votre bilan et sur éventuellement ce
que vous feriez si vous étiez réélu dans
un peu plus de deux semaines mais juste
avant de commencer on est à 48 heures du
1er tour de l'élection présidentielle il
y a 5 ans au Louvre le soir de votre
élection dans votre discours de victoire
vous disiez ceci je ferai tout durant
les 5 années qui viennent pour que les
Français n'aient plus aucune raison de
voter pour les extrêmes est-ce que vous
avez échoué
un homme seul ne peut pas tout résoudre
on va parfois le fait de reproche de
d'essayer
je pense que les sujets auxquels on
s'est attaqué on a commencé à les régler
et ils ont ils nourrissaient les
extrêmes
le chômage le chômage de masse qui est
pour moi une maladie française de très
long terme et on voit que durant ces
cinq années on a baissé de plus de
points le chômage c'est pour moi un des
un des vrais acquis de ce quinquennat il
y a un million de créations dedans on
est passé de 9,6 à 7,4% de taux de
chômeurs c'est ce qui fait dire que pour
la première fois depuis 40 ans on peut
aller vers le plein emploi si on
continue ce même effort dans les 5 ans
qui viennent on n'a rien on a commencé à
réindustrialiser le pays on crée plus
d'usines qu'on enferme ce qui était pas
arrivé depuis 30 ans on crée plus
d'emplois industriels qu'on en détruit
ce qui était là aussi par arriver depuis
longtemps donc ça c'est batailles sont
gagnées elles nourrissait les extrêmes
par contre quand on regarde les choses
les peurs sont là et la peur climatique
la peur de l'autre il faut bien dire ce
qui est
avec ces aspects les plus
contestables
on a pas réussi à y apporter une réponse
suffisamment crédible pour que les gens
se détournent massivement des extrêmes
ça veut dire que le monde extrême droite
c'est un vote irrationnel non je
respecte moi tous les électeurs mais je
pense que c'est un quand je regarde
aujourd'hui les arguments qui sont
imposés c'est un vote qui d'abord
s'appuie sur un rejet de l'immigration
faut bien dire ça fait partie des
thématiques un rejet aussi une tension
en tout cas avec la religion musulmane
et beaucoup de confusion dans ces sujets
et quand je regarde les positions qui
ont été prises par l'extrême droite quel
que soit les candidate ou le candidat de
l'extrême droite qui se présente à cette
élection c'est beaucoup de des liens
assez certain avec le complotisme et
durant les deux ans de pandémie un peu
tout et son contraire qui a été dit de
manière assez inquiétante
et donc oui c'est jouer avec les peurs
beaucoup et après ce sont des
propositions de court terme parfois
totalement non financés ou démagogiques
comme sur le pouvoir d'achat on pourrait
revenir puisque c'est un de vos thèmes
qui qui je crois peuvent donner le
sentiment que c'est une réponse crédible
moi je ne pense pas j'essaierai de
démontrer pourquoi mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que moi je veux
essayer de convaincre toutes les
électrices et tous les électeurs pour
les convaincre justement il y a
énormément de questions qu'on a reçu et
on va mais vous avez raison le c'est pas
aujourd'hui et on le voit dans toutes
les sociétés européennes et la plupart
des sociétés démocratiques occidentales
occidentales les extrêmes montent et il
y a une inquiétude dans nos sociétés il
y a un ébranlement et qui passe surtout
ces sujets et donc moi je pense que ne
le c'est aussi pour ça que je suis
engagé je pense qu'il faut
continuer à s'indigner face aux
injustices mais il faut répondre à ses
peurs par des voilà une vision de
société et essayer d'apporter cette
vision d'espoir cette inquiétude elle
tourne beaucoup autour du pouvoir
d'achat on a reçu énormément de
questions sur les salaires les prix je
vous propose tout de suite d'écouter la
première question elle vous est posée
par Christelle
monsieur le Président bonjour ma
question est la suivante à partir de
quel salaire considérez-vous que l'on
peut vivre correctement en France
alors ça dépend où on vit parce que
c'est simple le vivre correctement c'est
à dire le pouvoir d'achat c'est la
rencontre d'un salaire et d'autres
revenus peut-être parce qu'on peut avoir
des aides etc des compléments et d'un
coup de la vie et le coût de la vie il
est pas le même à Paris à 3 à Amiens ou
en grande ruralité parce que le coût du
logement
à Paris avec un SMIC on ne peut pas
vivre on peut pas se loger déjà il faut
être très clair c'est aussi pour ça que
on a continué d'augmenter plusieurs
plusieurs professions et malgré ça c'est
professions ne peuvent pas se loger dans
Paris donc
on ne vit pas bien avant un certain
niveau de revenus quand on est revenu à
Paris
pour bien vivre quand je regarde le coup
d'un loyer d'un livre c'est assez dur de
bien vivre en dessous de 3000 euros par
mois à Paris si on est honnête les
choses vous pouvez pas vivre avec un
SMIC est-ce que Christelle aussi
souligne une certaine manière c'est que
c'est de plus en plus difficile alors on
peut y venir
moi je pense que c'est un des vrais un
des vrais sujets de société qui pose la
question qui est en profondeur pour moi
la première réponse qu'on peut apporter
elle est sur le travail et les revenus
d'abord moi je pense qu'il faut
simplifier les revenus et les et les
aides parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui n'ont pas un travail à temps complet
qui ont besoin d'aide on y reviendra
peut-être en parlant des des plus jeunes
mais aussi des gens qui ont des
accidents de la vie sont en bord du
chemin donc il y a une des réformes que
je veux faire qui me paraît très
importantes pour pouvoir vivre pas bien
vivre mais déjà essayé de vivre
dignement et avoir ces subsides c'est ce
que j'appelle la solidarité à la source
il y a aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines
de milliers voire millions de nos
compatriotes qui ont droit à des aides
RSA à l'occasion familiale APL et autres
qui par la complexité de nos règles n'y
ont pas accès et comme on a fait le
prélèvement à la source qui a permis de
beaucoup simplifier nos vies je
t'inquiétant au début mais on l'a fait
ça a marché je veux faire cette
solidarité à la source qui permettra de
supprimer des économies au fond qu'on
fait qui sont indignes qui sont des
économies sur les très pauvres et de
lutter contre la fraude ensuite il y a
le travail
pour le travail durant le quinquennat
qui vient de s'écouler ça a été montré
par tous les organismes indépendants il
y a eu les plus grands gains de pouvoir
d'achat des 15 dernières années en
général mais en particulier pour les
Françaises et les Français qui
travaillent et qui sont plutôt au bas de
l'échelle et auxquels faisaient
implicitement référence madame et donc
là qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a supprimé
la taxe d'habitation typiquement
dans les villes etc c'est plusieurs
milliers d'euros parfois par an
deuxièmement on a baissé de 5 milliards
l'impôt sur le revenu ce qui représente
plusieurs centaines d'euros parce qu'on
a surtout concentré sur les bas revenus
troisièmement au niveau du SMIC on a
augmenté ce qu'on appelle la prime
d'activité de 90 euros par mois des
millions de personnes il y a pas se
ressenti là je vais prendre un exemple
très concret une étude de lyrique qui
dit sur un nom que les pattes ont
augmenté de près de 12,9% sur notre côté
je vais y venir vous vous êtes sur les
prix moi je suis déjà sur le non mais il
faut faire les deux le revenu et les
prix parce que les prix après il y a une
partie qui ne dépend pas de vous donc je
continue sur le revenu ça c'est ce qu'on
a fait donc j'assume moi d'avoir
accompagné les personnes qui travaillent
et d'avoir aussi engagé des
revalorisations de travailleurs
historiques 2 millions de Françaises
français qui travaillent dans les
métiers de la santé ont été revalorisés
avec le Ségur entre 184 et plus de 400
revenir après plus en détail pareil on a
donc on va continuer ce mouvement donc
ça c'est pour le travail qu'est-ce que
je veux faire dans les années qui
viennent si les Françaises et les
Français me font confiance il y a une
chose pour moi qui est très importante
c'est que c'est le partage de la valeur
ajoutée et ce que j'ai appelé en
reprenant des runes formule qui
circulait le dividende salarié au fond
les entreprises là sont en train de
faire cette paradoxe beaucoup de profits
à partir de la sortie de crise covid on
l'a vu beaucoup de profits et ça retombe
pas dans les poches de l'argent et
distribué aux actionnaires très bien moi
je critique pas ça si vous avez de
l'argent vous le mettez en entreprise
que vous soyez payé comme actionnaire ça
c'est la vie d'une entreprise par contre
salariés en profite il faut que les
salariés en profitent il y a deux
manières d'en profiter les négociations
annuelles ok mais négociation annuelle
on va vous dire ça ne dépend pas que du
résultat d'une année c'est sûr c'est
après vous le gardez tout le reste de la
carrière l'époque aujourd'hui le niveau
des salaires n'augmente pas autant que
celui de l'inflation parce qu'on va et
ça on va le corriger je pourrais vous
dire comment mais moi ce que je veux là
dessus c'est qu'on aille plus loin et
qu'on dise quand l'entreprise va mieux
et qu'elle fait des profits le salarié
de m'en profiter on l'oblige on est
obligé d'entreprise et donc ce que je
veux faire c'est avoir en effet une
règle qui dit quand vous versez du
dividende vous devez soit avoir un
accord d'intéressement participation et
mettre de l'intéressement participation
soit parce que pour beaucoup de PME ils
veulent pas d'accord d'intéressement
participation parce qu'ils veulent pas
faire entrer au capital leur travail
soit vous prenez la prime pouvoir
d'achat que j'ai créé il y a trois ans
qui est limité aujourd'hui à 1000 euros
et vous le versez et donc un je mets en
place un mécanisme qui permet de rendre
obligatoire si je puis dire le fait de
dire quand je veux verser des dividendes
il faut partager le compte vous avez il
faut partager la valeur avec les
salariés et on l'avait beaucoup
simplifié avec la loi des pactes
deuxième point
la prime d'activité la prime de
participation justement au pouvoir
d'achat je la passe de 1000
à 3000 euros le problème c'est que les
trois dernières années de l'augmenter
mais elle n'a bénéficié qu'à 4,8
millions bénéficiaires pour 500 euros de
moyenne c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous
allez monter un plafond alors que le
plafond est pas atteint en moyenne mais
deuxièmement de remarque le premier
c'est que ces 4 millions et demi s'il y
avait pas eu cette prime ils auraient
rien eu rien eu 4 millions et demi c'est
pas rien comme maintenant je vais mettre
un mécanisme d'obligation bah soit
l'entreprise elle crée un mais de
l'intéressement participation soit elle
va faire ce qu'on appelle la Peppa ou la
prime Macron pour d'autres fameuses de
pouvoir d'achat et je monte le plafond à
6000 euros sans charge ni impôts et ça
ça va être dans le dialogue social parce
que la vérité tout le monde voit que le
coup de la vie augmente et en le faisant
passer dès cet été ce qui est ce que je
veux faire c'est les Françaises et les
Français me font confiance et à ce
moment-là une négo qui est assez des
bénéfices le prix de la vie augmente il
faut que je puisse avoir Emmanuel Macron
ça c'est très très important Emmanuel
Macron à côté de ça il y a évidemment le
coût de la vie justement vous venez de
dire tout à l'heure
le pouvoir d'achat de salariés c'est clé
parce que c'est un changement de
philosophie c'est et ça va avec la
raison d'être au passage vous avez dit
vos règles ça passera par la loi ou par
la règle c'est quoi ce qu'on a commencé
avec
justement la loi pacte c'est le mettre
la raison d'être dans l'entreprise et
donc ça il faut regarder si on va
jusqu'à la loi mais en tout cas moi je
suis pour la je suis pour que le
mécanisme que ça ne soit pas très bien
je suis pour que l'entreprise qui qui
est un mécanisme systématique vous
versez du dividende il faut qu'il y ait
ou intéressement participation ou Peppa
qui est utilisé on avance pouvoir
d'achat vous avez dit que le port
d'achat va augmenter pour la plupart des
français notamment ceux qui travaillent
la question d'Emmanuel va un peu
permettre de nuancer ses propos c'est
pas les miens simplement c'est les tous
les instituts on écoute même l'Insee
écoutons tout de même Emmanuel
bonjour monsieur Macron comment se
fait-il que durant votre quinquennat en
France les personnes les plus aisées a
vu leur pouvoir d'achat augmenter de
2,8% tandis que les personnes les plus
modestes ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat
diminué de 0,5%. autrement dit pourquoi
instaurez-vous en France une société où
les inégalités et les écarts de richesse
ne cessent d'augmenter merci pour votre
réponse et la source est l'Institut des
politiques publiques alors c'est leur
première version qu'ils ont corrigé
suite à échange avec le gouvernement
puisque personne le décile qui est
évoqué n'a pas perdu donc l'Institut des
politiques publiques à corrigé cela
l'Insee qui est un institut indépendant
qui a pris en compte en particulier
toutes les mesures de solidarité parce
que l'étude que je pensais citer et
celle qui ne prenait pas en compte les
mesures de solidarité pour les premiers
des cils
permet de corriger ça donc ce qui est
vrai c'est que il y a eu un gain de
pouvoir d'achat plus important pour les
risques pour les plus alors le plus non
le plus important il est pour les
classes moyennes si vous regardez même
l'Institut des politiques publiques ou
l'Insee le plus important et pour la
tranche que j'ai évoquais tout à l'heure
parce qu'elle a eu la baisse de la terre
pardon de l'impôt sur le revenu et la
prime d'activité mais pour mais pour
mais c'est tout à fait vrai qu'il y a eu
l'inégalité de se dire qu'aujourd'hui
un gain de pouvoir d'achat moyen qui n'a
pas d'équivalent dans les 15 années qui
ont précédé et il y a eu un vrai gain de
pouvoir d'achat pour les classes
moyennes d'où vient le gain de pouvoir
d'achat des plus aisés du fait qu'on a
mis en place la flat tax pour
l'investissement dans le capital et
qu'on a supprimé la part d'impôt sur la
fortune quand on réinvestit dans
l'économie je l'assume complètement
parce que ce sont des gens qui certes
ont gagné en pouvoir d'achat mais qui
ont réinvesti beaucoup dans l'économie
française là où avant il partait mais la
philosophie moi donc moi j'assume
totalement cette politique parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passait avant c'est pas
vrai qui gagnait moins de pouvoir
d'achat soit ils allaient ailleurs ils
en faisaient beaucoup plus en Belgique
ou autre et on perdait de notre capacité
à créer et à être attractif parce que ce
qui s'est passé derrière c'est grâce à
ça on a regagné de l'attractivité et on
a créé de l'emploi et de
l'investissement en France et vous ne
créez pas d'emploi et d'industrie s'il
n'y a pas du capital qui est attiré pour
investir ou du capital que vous gardez
pour être réinvesti par contre ce qui
m'importe moi beaucoup plus c'est de
corriger ces inégalités à la racine si
on prend le sujet des inégalités la clé
ce qu'on fait moins bien historiquement
en France que par exemple les modèles
nordiques c'est pas le sujet de la
répartition avec l'impôt c'est le sujet
de la correction des inégalités à la
racine et là on a commencé le travail
mais on est très loin d'avoir réussi à
aller jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire est-ce
que quand on est dans une famille
d'ouvriers
on arrive à accéder au classement
moyenne en une génération non et on
parle est-ce que quand même abandonné
même en droit n'est même en cassis voilà
et donc ça on a commencé à y répondre
avec le dédoublement des classes de
cpce1 ce que veut dire par là c'est que
moi la vraie lutte contre les inégalités
c'est l'école c'est d'aller beaucoup
plus loin ce qu'on a fait c'est pour ça
que c'est un des grands chantiers c'est
la santé c'est pour ça que c'est lutter
contre les inégalités de santé
pas tout à l'heure aujourd'hui alors
français qui nous regardent qui vont
supermarché qui prennent leur paquet de
pâtes qui est peut-être 10 20 30
centimes plus cher pour beaucoup
énormément de place à l'autre partie qui
n'ont pas l'impression que le pouvoir
d'achat augmenté mais c'est pas qu'une
impression parce que les chiffres ont
pas l'impression
parce que c'est vrai leur pouvoir
d'achat a augmenté durant les cinq
dernières années mais ces derniers mois
les prix ont beaucoup augmenté voilà et
les salaires n'ont pas suivi et les
salaires alors donc c'est pour ça
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement
une mesure très concrète on parle de la
TVA on sait que certains candidats
veulent baisser la TVA sur les produits
de première nécessité alors est-ce que
vous allez faire je vais d'abord il y a
le premier nécessité ou la TVA est déjà
à taux réduit c'est déjà
le cas et le passé à certains produits
qui ne sont pas et d'autres carrément
supprimer la TVA
que c'est pas possible en vertu de
l'Europe mais c'est les mêmes candidats
qui veulent sortir de l'Europe donc faut
pas céder mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ces derniers mois en effet les prix ont
beaucoup monté le SMIC a suivi au mois
d'octobre de mémoire il a dû monter d'un
peu près deux en janvier il a très peu
monté là au 1er mai il va monter entre
deux quatre et deux six bon derrière
c'est pour ça que moi je veux faire
cette prime de pouvoir d'achat c'est
donner la possibilité sans charge et
sans impôts d'augmenter il y aura des
négociations salariales qui clairement
vont suivre qu'est-ce que quel est pour
moi la réponse face à l'augmentation de
ces prix la première c'est qu'on a une
augmentation depuis la reprise avant la
guerre on a une augmentation des prix de
l'énergie pourquoi parce que le monde
est reparti d'un coup d'un seul de
manière
très forte et donc le prix du gaz de
l'électricité à flamber la guerre
n'arrange rien au contraire qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait on a fait une réponse qui
est beaucoup plus efficace que la baisse
de la TVA 5,5 parce que la candidate
d'extraités on a mis un bouclier
tarifaire votre électricité n'a
quasiment pas augmenté vous avez dû
prendre 5 % elle aurait dû augmenter
plus de 80 %. et ça vous garantissait
que durant tout un canon si vous êtes
réunis
la clé c'est pendant que les prix
s'envolent il faut garder le bouclier
c'est pour ça que je veux le garder
parce que cet été il y a pas de raison
que ça s'améliore beaucoup mais je veux
le garder tant que les prix s'envolent
et surtout je veux réformer les prix de
l'électricité au niveau européen parce
que nous nos prix de l'électricité ne
devrait pas dépendre du gaz on a très
peu de gaz dans notre mix donc changer
la formation du prix au niveau européen
le vaincre des partenaires oui mais on
est en train et au mois de mai on a un
Conseil européen sur la formation du
prix on a une nouvelle question attendez
je vais au bout bien sûr sur le gaz
on a une première augmentation de 35%.
nos voisins allemands italiens etc ils
ont eu plus de 100% d'augmentation du
gaz à ce moment là on a mis le bouclier
vous n'avez pas pris d'autres
augmentations ce qui veut dire que pour
un ménage qui se chauffe au gaz c'est
l'équivalent de 1200 euros par an
d'économie
de préservation de pouvoir d'achat et
pour l'électricité c'est en moyenne 300
euros par an d'équivalent d'économies
qu'on a fait à côté de ça on a mis le
chèque inflation les premières aides et
maintenant l'Aristote de 18 centimes sur
l'essence ce paquet là il est beaucoup
plus efficace que ce qui consiste à
baisser la TVA parce qu'on a protégé
d'augmentation de 50 60 parfois 80% là
où la TVA c'est un écart de 15 points
donc ça c'est beaucoup plus efficace on
va passer à la question suivante ensuite
pour l'alimentation juste d'un mot
l'alimentation qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire faut aider les agriculteurs dans
cette période parce que c'est simple un
agriculteur qui produit plus cher il
peut on peut pas lui dire tu vas garder
ton coup donc il faut tous qu'on accepte
que les produits agricoles les produits
alimentaires vont reprendre de la valeur
dans cette période donc c'est pour ça
que ce que je veux faire c'est mettre en
place un chèque alimentaire pour lutter
contre la précarité alimentaire et
accompagner les ménages les plus
modestes
ça c'est ce qu'on est à la discussion
avec d'ailleurs le monde agricole et les
partenaires sociaux moi je voudrais que
les entreprises elles puissent abonder
mais votre souhait à vous ce serait
combien il faut qu'on voit comment les
prix justement on arrive à les maîtriser
ou pas mais mon souhait c'est que ça
puisse couvrir aujourd'hui
on va passer peut-être à la question
suivante si vous me permettez parce que
il y a la question 3 justement qui est
basée sur la précarité étudiante et les
poser par Amandine
monsieur le Président j'aimerais savoir
du coup ce que vous comptez faire pour
aider les étudiants si vous êtes réélu
et merci d'avance pour votre réponse
moi sur le terrain justement j'ai
couvert c'est distribution alimentaire
il y avait un sentiment que l'État les
avait tout simplement abandonnés alors
je et c'est un sentiment qu'ils ont
encore aujourd'hui et on a vu pendant le
covid ces files d'attente de nombreuses
étudiants qui étaient là qui avait des
difficultés pour payer leur loyer qui
avait pas de quoi remplir leur frigo et
ses associations attendaient le soutien
de l'État et pour beaucoup n'ont pas eu
alors on sait qu'il y a eu le coup s'il
y a des choses qui ont été mises en
place le groupe c'est l'état oui
justement exactement
étrangers qui étaient là dans des
situations difficiles et qui était dans
ces files alimentaires parce que je
reprenais les chiffres pendant la crise
covid d'abord il n'y a aucun pays
qui a autant aidé au total ces étudiants
que nous on a à peu près un tiers de nos
étudiants qui sont beaucoup qui sont
boursiers dans notre pays on a supprimé
dans le quinquennat qui vient de
s'écouler on a baissé de 125 euros la
sécurité sociale étudiante
ça et ça ça va rester puisque c'est une
décision que j'ai prise on a à côté de
ça je regardais distribuer 11 millions
de repas à un euro on a accompagné
pendant la crise 750 000 boursiers avec
en plus de la Bourse une aide de 150
euros en plus de tout ce que ce qui a
été fait avec les CROUS donc je veux
dire je peux pas laisser dire qu'on a
laissé tomber les gens c'est pas vrai
mais en plus de ça il y a eu le chèque
psy l'accompagnement etc donc il faut
quand même collectivement que et
vous-même vous avez fait le constat le
13 janvier vous disiez bien sûr nous
n'avons jamais vu autant de précarité
étudiante mais parce que les solutions
sont peut-être pas suffisantes
je peux pas laisser dire qu'on a rien
fait après on a un vrai sujet avec les
étudiants étrangers et l'aide à ces
étudiants étrangers parce que Campus
France prend beaucoup mais c'est vrai
que on a un sujet logement et autres
donc quel est le problème structurel
qu'on a je regardais les chiffres en
venant vous voir on a 40% des jeunes qui
ce mot est affront à l'ambassade
déco-habitant qui vivent plus avec leurs
parents parce que c'est l'inégalité elle
est là aussi beaucoup quand je suis
d'une famille qui
la décision l'erreur qui a été faite
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas voulu déjuger le
gouvernement à ce moment-là c'était une
décision de régulation budgétaire qui
datait du gouvernement d'avant donc
c'est un vrai ce procès est injuste
parce que à côté de ça on a rendu un
système qui est beaucoup plus juste
puisque maintenant les appels elles sont
contemporaines à votre statut
c'est-à-dire que les appels à l'avant de
calculer sur vos revenus de l'année
précédente maintenant elle correspondent
à vos revenus contemporains ce qui va me
permettre de faire la solidarité à la
source et surtout en baissant de 125
euros la sécurité sociale étudiante
c'est beaucoup plus juste que d'avoir
maintenu les appels alors ce que je veux
non la réforme que je veux faire c'est
une réforme des bourses étudiantes et
des aides de la 5 euros par mois et la
mutuelle c'était sur l'année oui enfin
si on fait bien sûr mais ça reste quand
même on est d'accord
et à côté de ça je pourrais dire que
pour les tous les étudiants qui
travaillent aussi ils ont été gagnants
et que les accompagnements qu'on a fait
avec les CROUS ils ont été largement et
gagnants mais je m'en satisfais pas ce
que je veux c'était une réaction à la
polémique
non pas du tout la polémique pour moi
elle a été prise quand on prend quand on
prend une polémique on avance
je veux qu'on lance maintenant une
grande réforme pour moi des bourses et
des aides au logement étudiants où on
doit par la concertation réussir et ça
va avec pour moi le grand dispositif de
solidarité à la source simplifier et
bien mieux prendre en compte la réalité
au quotidien de nos étudiants tant qu'on
la prendra pas ce sera pas bon après il
y a tous les sujets des jobs étudiants
adaptés moi je suis pour développer
aussi beaucoup plus de jobs étudiants
adaptés en lien avec les universités et
les CROUS mais qui permettent de faire
des études et de gagner et d'avoir un
revenu et c'est aussi ça parce qu'il y a
les aides qu'on doit nous adapter et
renforcer et il y a aussi la possibilité
d'avoir un revenu par du travail qu'on
fait à côté de ces études mais qui
permet de suivre décemment ces études
d'un mot est-ce que quand on étudiant
doit travailler je pense que quand on
est étudiant parce que pour beaucoup
c'est compliqué justement de cumuler les
deux il y a des c'est compliqué quand on
a des emplois qui sont qui ne
correspondent pas la vie étudiante
emploi du temps qui sont à rallonge on
commence à 8h le matin on finit c'est
vraiment 20h et après on enchaîne
collectivement est-ce qu'on sait pas se
débrouiller intelligemment on a des
étudiants qui malgré les aides disent il
faudrait que j'ai 100 euros de plus par
mois on a des bibliothèques
universitaires qu'on n'arrive pas à
ouvrir le week-end en soirée est-ce que
ce serait pas un job étudiant
intelligent qui est quand même
compatible avec le fait de faire des
études de dire je fais x heures par
semaine ou je suis à la bibliothèque qui
plus est je peux bosser certains l'ont
fait on l'a développé pendant la crise
je paye un L2 un L3 ou un M1 pour faire
du tutorat et je le paye mieux que ce
qu'on avait proposé pendant la crise je
prends le but parce que c'était le
reproche qu'on m'avait fait et donc je
le paye ça c'est des job étudiants qui
sont compatibles qui sont intelligents
qui sont qualifiants et qui me
permettent de faire des études et
d'avoir un revenu qui va compléter ma
bourse dans le cadre étudiantain et qui
est pas un boulot que je fais 35 heures
par semaine on va commencer au
générationnel on fait un saut
générationnel et on va s'intéresser avec
Justine à la question des retraites
pourquoi décaler l'âge de la retraite à
65 ans alors qu'à cet âge-là une grande
partie des plus pauvres sont déjà morts
directe
la réalité c'est que on vit plus
longtemps on vit plus longtemps en bonne
santé après il y a des inégalités devant
l'espérance de vie c'est tout à fait
vrai donc il faut les prendre en compte
les 5 % les plus pauvres hommes meurent
à 60 et 11,7 ans en moyenne là où les 5%
les plus riches à 84,4 exactement c'est
une inégalité insupportable et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut la prendre en
compte dans la retraite ce que je veux
faire alors allez-y et donc la première
chose que je dis à Justine
aujourd'hui on a un système nous tous
qui est un trésor français qu'on a créé
après la deuxième guerre mondiale ça
s'appelle le système par répartition
c'est nous parce que tous les trois on a
cette situation les actifs qui payons la
retraite des retraités on ne cotise pas
pour nous-mêmes l'idée qu'on s'en fait
et donc si les équilibres entre les âges
qui rendent possible l'équilibre du
système aujourd'hui notre système il est
déséquilibré et il est pour les 15 ans
qui viennent
pas pour très longtemps pour les 15 ans
qui viennent ce qui veut dire que chaque
année on accepte qu'il est déséquilibrés
on l'équilibre sur les générations qui
ne sont pas encore nées et ils
continuera de l'être après si on ne fait
pas des réformes soyons clairs parce
qu'on va c'est pas ce que dit le corps
si le corps il dit le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites il y a 5 ans
et il y a pas de problème de financement
quand j'ai été élu six mois après il a
dit le contraire c'est pour ça qu'à ce
moment-là j'avais pas compris non ça
veut dire qu'il change ses hypothèses
macroéconomiques en fonction du cycle la
réalité on le sait bien mais dans tous
les pays européens travaillent ont un
âge légal qui entre 65 et 68 ans on est
le plus décalé même l'Italie l'Espagne
l'Allemagne etc
on continue à avoir une espérance de vie
qui s'allonge et une espérance de vie en
bonne santé on a un système par
répartition le système actuel il est
injuste je vais vous dire pourquoi là je
l'égal et ça 62 ans si je prends les
salariés du secteur privé hors carrière
longue l'âge moyen de départ il est
au-dessus de 63 ans et demi
d'annulation de la décote et de 67 ans
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a des millions
de gens les plus modestes les carrières
ont beaucoup de femmes qui n'ont pas le
tout leur droit qui vont travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans c'est ça le système donc
moi je dis si on veut moi je ne veux pas
que le système reste déséquilibré parce
que je ne veux pas transférer la charge
sur les générations qui sont à naître ou
les plus jeunes je veux le rééquilibrer
de manière progressive pour gagner aussi
en droits sociaux il y a trois moyens de
le faire soit je baisse les pensions je
suis contre c'est pas juste parce que
nos aînés ils ont le même problème que
nos étudiants donc je veux faire deux
choses pour les retraités monter la
pension minimale quand on a tous ces
droits à 1100 euros elle est aujourd'hui
en dessous de 990 vregan pouvoir d'achat
c'est juste deuxième chose je veux
pouvoir indexer les pensions sur
l'inflation et de faire des cet été si
je veux faire ça je peux pas c'était le
cas longtemps et qui a des indexé en
2019 non pardon j'ai rien indexé en 2019
ça avait été désindexé depuis 2012 dans
un contexte qui était très peu
impressionniste avec la crise des gilets
jaunes j'ai réindexé donc c'est
l'inverse simplement là notre ind
parce que notre notre espérance pas par
quelque chose de plus solidaire pourquoi
est-ce que les gens comme moi c'est ne
cotisent pas plus et travaille peut-être
plus longtemps que les secondes cordées
et bien nous ont tellement été pendant
la crise justement j'y viens c'est que
c'est ce que je veux faire de plusieurs
manières donc un on va décaler là je
légale là je les gale on va le pousser à
raison de 4 mois par an donc c'est de
manière progressive les gens qui partent
à la retraite cette année ou dans les
mois qui viennent on passe leur âge qui
sera décalé l'année prochaine on le
décalera de 4 mois ce soit 62,4 mois
quand vous regardez le nombre de gens
qui partent en fait après 62 ans il y
aura pas un impact énorme et puis après
progressivement de quatre mois en quatre
mois en faisant ça première chose on va
garder un dispositif de carrière longue
ça veut dire que les gens qui ont
commencé à travailler plus tôt il faut
qu'ils puissent partir eux avant et donc
il faut qu'ils aient un avantage
qui est à négocier aujourd'hui ils ont
deux ans de moins que l'âge légal il
faut quand moi je suis plutôt pour qu'on
transpose cet avantage je veux pas
présenter la négociation on va venir que
je verrouille tout donc il passera sur
63 il faut qu'on puisse faut que les
gens qui ont commencé à travailler plus
jeune puisse partir plus jeune mais il
partiront quand même plus tard
qu'aujourd'hui ils partiront plus tard
qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'ils tout le
monde va un peu décaler mais pas peu
injuste ou pas c'est pas injuste parce
que il gagne aussi en espérance de vie
comme tout comme tous les autres mais
c'est juste parce que comme ils ont
travaillé plus jeune si ils ont tout
leur ils ont un âge légal plutôt la
question après c'est ce qu'ils veulent
partir plus tôt mais ils auront le droit
la deuxième chose c'est pour
l'invalidité on laissera à 55 ans la
troisième chose c'est que je veux
rouvrir une une négociation sur les
critères de pénibilité ça ça rejoint ce
que disait Justine c'est à dire que en
effet il y a des métiers quels sont les
métiers où l'espérance de vie n'est pas
la même c'est quand on travaille de nuit
donc là il faut qu'on ait un bonus c'est
quand on travaille avec des produits
chimiques avec des produits dangereux
celui-là il y a un impact sur la santé
c'est quand on travaille
de manière physique avec d'être qu'on
est un bonus c'est quand on travaille
avec des produits chimiques avec des
produits dangereux où là il y a un
impact sur la santé c'est quand on
travaille
de manière physique avec des troubles
musculoosquelettiques qui font qu'on
peut pas travailler aussi longtemps avec
même il faut penser des deuxième partie
de carrière vous revenez à ce qu'on
faisait par le passé non en fait par le
passé on a fait quelques mandat non
c'est faux parce que on avait des
critères qui n'ont jamais été appliqués
avant le mandat et qui avait posé des
premières règles de pénibilité mais qui
consistait qui était beaucoup trop large
et qui consistait quasiment à recréer
des régimes spéciaux pourquoi les
régimes spéciaux c'est plus juste c'est
qu'on les a créé avant en créant par un
régime pour la SNCF du coup on était on
rentrait dans des bureaux à la SNCF on
pouvait partir à bien avant l'âge légal
c'était pas juste parce que quand je
travaille dans un bureau c'est pas plus
pénible personne et donc il faut que je
suivie de la pénibilité pour les bureaux
ça pardon ça dépend les bureaux mais les
continuer oui enfin très honnêtement ce
dont je parle ce qui sont des vrais
l'espérance de vie quand elle est elle
descend ce sont des métiers exposés
c'est des métiers on est transporteur
c'est des métiers où on a on porte et on
est dans les abattoirs donc tout ça faut
quand même être cohérent les uns avec
les autres pour ça que j'ai toujours dit
c'est de travail en soi qui est pénible
mais ces taches là sont pénibles et donc
je suis pour l'individualisation de ces
normes et que là on est un vrai dialogue
social et que ça donne un bonus et que
là on puisse partir plus tôt on va
résolument donc ça je crois que c'est
juste et si on veut pouvoir financer ces
mesures de justice parce que faut pas se
tromper toutes ces professions là je
veux dire une femme qui a une carrière
fracturée à qui on a pas reconnu des
droits qui a été obligé de s'arrêter
pour ses enfants qui est aide-soignante
qui est un métier dur physique
aujourd'hui elle va travailler jusqu'à
67 ans c'est ça la réalité personne
trouve que c'est injuste aujourd'hui or
vous avez des centaines de milliers de
femmes qui sont aide-soignantes qui ont
des métiers physiquement durs qui vont
jusqu'à 67 ans avec le système que je
propose elles pourront partir même avant
les 65 ans Emmanuel Macron je veux ces
avancées
et les cabinets de conseils allons-y
envoie si une
bonjour monsieur Macron l'État français
aide des centaines de millions d'euros
chaque année plus d'un milliard de
rondes 2021 des cabinets de conciles
privés pour des analyses conseils sur
tous types de sujets pourquoi ne pas
plutôt investir cet argent dans le
développement du gouvernement par
exemple pour acquérir le matériel
nécessaire ou pour créer des emplois
dédiés à ça pour que par la suite
lui-même puisse répondre à ses besoins
alors c'est une très bonne approche de
le poser comme ça oui mais je vais
essayer d'expliquer pas trop longtemps
pas trop longuement c'est normal d'avoir
de demander des conseils extérieurs
quand on a une entreprise une
collectivité locale ou le gouvernement
parce qu'on sait pas tout faire tout
seul parfois il faut pouvoir regarder ce
qui a été fait ailleurs avoir des
conseils etc donc ça c'est normal je
pense que chez brut vous le faites
les collectivités locales le font les
états le font
donc ça ce premier point faut pas tout
confondre
on le fait pas chez brut à mon avis si
parce que je pense que vous internalisez
pas tout évidemment parce que quand on
met ses conseils ça c'est ma kiné c'est
quelques dizaines de millions d'euros
c'est totalement faux les chiffres qui
ont été donnés là on met toutes les
prestations y compris informatique je
doute que sur 1% des total au minimum
toutes les prestations mais donc c'est
comme si je disais à brut vous faites
tout en interne je pense pas que tout
vos systèmes la différence est une
entreprise privée que l'État c'est
l'argent du monde vous avez totalement
raison je regarde les copains le rapport
du Sénat monte très bien allez voir le
rapport du Sénat il est public l'État
français c'est le gouvernement c'est 850
millions à peu près on arrive au
milliards quand on rajoute les 40
principaux opérateurs qui ont fait 150
millions les Allemands c'est deux fois
plus que nous non mais pardon
chez brut on n'a pas des salariés qui
bossent sur un sujet et en même temps un
cabinet de conseils sur le même personne
c'est pas Boris il a un peu surpris
quand il a travaillé sur les premiers
jours d'une vie il a appris le cabinet
anglais travaillent en même temps sur le
même sujet c'est pas moi de répondre
c'est pas moi qui ai passé le contrat
mais le ministre mais moi j'en pense que
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut très
concrètement dire c'est d'abord c'est
normal qui a qui accède des prestataires
extérieurs deux est-ce que la France a
une pratique aberrante non c'est 0,3 %
de notre masse salariale c'est deux fois
moins que les Allemands trois fois moins
que les Anglais donc faut savoir raison
garder qu'on part pas exactement les
mêmes choses on compare exactement les
mêmes choses regardez le rapport du
Sénat 3 quand je regarde ce chiffre
c'est pas du tout des choses dans les
trous les trois quarts de ce dont on
parle ce sont des prestations
informatiques et de systèmes
d'information et en particulier l'année
2021 c'est je regarde les dépenses ce
qui a été fait pour les systèmes
d'information et les modalités liées au
covid et pour la lutte contre le cyber
et en effet là on a pris des gens pour
s'équiper et ensuite on a internalisé et
par rapport à ce que disait monsieur ce
sont des choses d'ailleurs on a baissé
en 2022 de 20% cette dépense parce que
précisément on a réussi à internaliser
les choses donc ce que j'aime pas si
vous voulez c'est qu'on a un épouvantail
en plus c'est anglo-saxon ça fait pas
beau mais qu'ils étaient il paye pas
d'impôts ce qui me scandalise je me suis
battu en européen contre ça et on va y
répondre nous en vrai moi je suis pas
dans la culture d'un mouvement c'est
grave comme ça
c'est des Français aussi mais non mais
c'est plein de français mais c'est y
compris de l'entreprise tartemall ou
match pro ce sont des gens que vous
connaissez pas du tout qui sont des des
qui ont des petits cabinets qui vous
aident et qui qui ont qui nous ont aidé
sur les systèmes d'information et ce qui
est important par rapport à votre
question ce sont des gens qui à chaque
fois doivent apporter une compétence que
vous n'avez pas dans l'état et donc par
rapport à tous ces contrats 1 il y a pas
de complaisance 2 moi je veux bien je
suis candidat je réponds tout et je
réponds à toutes les questions mais le
président de la République il signe
aucun de ces contrats ce sont les
administrations qui les signes un
ministre un directeur d'administration
un opérateur pour le gouvernement et
trois non mais juste pour être clair
juste quand même dernière question parce
que c'est que ça a quand même beaucoup
ajouté notamment les réseaux et vos
oppositions non mais vous pouvez donc
répondre on évoque beaucoup des liens
entre mackenza et vous notamment pour
votre campagne électorale qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça mais je dis 1 moi je
n'ai jamais fait une intervention pour
qu'il y a quelque chose qui soit signé
avec ma kinzee de la France et on doit
s'en honorer depuis le début des années
90 les fameuses loi sapins encadre les
marchés publics comme très peu d'autres
pays européens on a constamment renforcé
sous le quinquennat précédent et souvent
quinquennat et donc quand il y a un code
des marchés
mais non mais moi j'ai pas de lien
personnel j'ai jamais travaillé pour ma
kinzee mais MacDo a pu travailler pour
vous non mais ma kinzee ce sont des gens
que je connais parce que il se trouve
que moi j'étais dans le secteur privé
donc sont des gens avec qui j'ai
travaillé par ailleurs ce sont des
cabinets qui conseillent des tas
d'entreprises donc que j'ai déjà vu et
même les opposants qui contestent
oublient qu'ils les ont beaucoup fait
travailler parce qu'il y a 10 ans quand
il y avait des cabinets qui faisaient la
réforme de l'État c'était makin disait
qu'il les faisait pour beaucoup donc je
veux dire c'est un jeu d'hypocrite
complet cette affaire mais ce qui est
important c'est que ce que je veux je
veux que ce soit très clair pour toutes
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent il y a
pas d'intervention de président de la
République sur les contrats 2
chacun de ces contrats il est scruté et
s'il y a un problème il peut aller
devant le juge c'est code des marchés
publics 3 la règle c'est que on doit pas
mettre quelqu'un d'extérieur quand on a
la compétence en interne ça c'est du
contrôle c'est contrôle que font les
administrations que font le Parlement et
là c'est du mauvais utilisation d'argent
public moi j'ai pas eu de démonstration
qui en avait s'il y en a il faut
évidemment les radiquer 4 on a une
pratique qui n'est pas déviante il faut
pas tout simplifier parce que si on veut
avoir le meilleur service pour l'État et
les collectivités locales il est hyper
important d'avoir les meilleurs qui nous
aident à former à former nos propres
je me félicite qu'on est ouvert des
enquêtes et les contrôles mais moi c'est
un combat que je mène depuis 5 ans que
toutes les entreprises qui font du
profit en France paye des impôts en
France c'est un combat ça marche pas si
on le fait tout seul sinon ils partent à
la frontière on l'a mené en européen les
Européens nous dit il faut le faire au
niveau international c'est le cas la
France s'est battue on a eu un accord à
l'OCDE sous française on va enfin passer
cette impomélie on va pouvoir avancer
sur la suite parce qu'on a reçu
énormément de questions de la communauté
brute sur l'écologie et on va écouter la
première elle est Juliette
bonsoir Monsieur Macron ma question ce
sera qu'est ce que vous pouvez affirmer
avoir mis en place pour limiter le
réchauffement climatique durant votre
mandat et est-ce que vous trouvez ça
suffisant
merci en complément de la question
suffisance ça renvoie aussi au rapport
du GIEC vous l'avez sûrement découvert
il y a quelques jours qui pose trois ans
2025 donc le prochain Président de la
République française aura géré ce délai
terrible trois ans pour vivre dans un
monde encore vivable
je vous laisse donc répondre à la
question c'est une immense question
c'est une et en fond cette c'est une
question qui structure
c'est pas juste une case si je puis dire
une politique c'est une question qui va
structurer notre manière de vivre et de
produire et donc pour moi l'écologie
elle fait partie de à la fois notre
de la de la qualité de vie on va avoir
de notre capacité à transformer le monde
et c'est une politique d'émancipation au
même titre que l'éducation la culture
elle est au cœur de ce qu'on doit faire
je vais répondre parce que j'ai une
question très précise je vais y répondre
durant les 5 années qui viennent de
s'écouler on a réduit l'émission de gaz
à effet de serre deux fois plus vite que
durant les cinq années qui précédaient
on en parle souvent de la France qui a
été condamnée pour son inaction elle a
été condamnée pour ne pas tenir ses
engagements pour les années qui
précédemment mandat parce que je prends
tout à chaque fois donc c'était jusqu'à
2017 de mémoire révolue au début 2018 je
considère pas que j'avais développé
toutes les politiques publiques
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait principalement
pour le climat durant les 5 années 1 je
me félicite d'être celui qui a pris la
décision d'arrêter les grands projets
qui étaient fous pour le climat on en
parle plus aujourd'hui il reste une
centrale à charbon non attendez c'est je
parle pas des centrales je vais venir
mais les grands projets
ça c'est la production d'énergie mais
les grands projets c'était Notre Dame
des langues ça fait 15 qu'on le traînait
je me souviens dans toutes les émissions
on en parlait d'abord moi j'avais plutôt
dit je vais le maintenir bravache je
disais je veux tenir pour pas céder
devant les blocages
pourquoi j'ai dit que je le ferais pas
parce que j'ai fait le bilan climatique
et donc j'ai dit c'est ça n'a plus aucun
sens j'ai arrêté le projet européen
parce que les écolos ont été non pardon
enfin alors pour le coup si j'avais
pensé que c'était bon alors je l'aurais
fait d'accord mais parce que très
sincèrement c'était un projet qui ne
correspondait plus à nos besoins au
modèle de développement et qui était
aberrant d'un point de vue climatique
j'ai arrêté de repas City centre
commercial dans le nord de dans le
Val-d'Oise
j'ai arrêté la montagne d'or
donc ça c'est des résultats aussi les
énergies renouvelables aujourd'hui euro
stade qui nous dit que la France est le
seul pays qui n'a pas répondu ça c'est
tout à fait vrai et je précise parce que
tous les projets
la Cour des comptes européennes épingle
la France comme plusieurs autres pays
parce que la France subventionne
davantage les énergies fossiles que les
énergies renouvelables alors ça rapporte
il y a quelques jours oui mais ça c'est
ça c'est un peu injuste parce que nous
en fait on a un modèle qui dépend très
peu du fossile parce qu'on a beaucoup de
nucléaires mais je vais répondre à vous
deux je passe à l'énergie donc un j'ai
arrêté les grands projets c'est bon pour
le climat c'est mon bilan 2 production
d'énergie nous on a un modèle
honnêtement j'y suis pour rien je vais
pas me jeter des fleurs on est le pays
qui émet le moins de l'un des pays qui
est moins aimé le moins de tonnes de CO2
par habitant pour produire son énergie
parce qu'on a le nucléaire c'est pour ça
aussi que je dis que tous les projets
quand j'écoute le projet de Yannick
Jadot Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui propose de
sortir d'une clé rapidement ce sont des
projets fous d'un point de vue
climatique parce que ce sont des projets
qui ont une crédibilité zéro on peut pas
supprimer et remplacer le nucléaire par
le renouvelable et d'ailleurs l'exemple
de l'Allemagne le monde ce sont des
projets qui feront réimporter du gaz ou
réouvrir des centrales à charbon donc 1
ça c'est pas loin de ce que vous
proposez en 2017 faux ce qu'il propose
eux ah non moi j'ai jamais proposé de
sortir en totalité du nucléaire eux pas
totalement non plus et progressivement
jusqu'au 2050 c'est quand même un an et
propose pas tout de suite mais propose
d'en sortir totalement c'est impossible
le rapport drte l'a très bien dit c'est
impossible sauf à couvrir la France
d'éolienne et ce serait trop long mais
moi je veux être sobre mais non mais
attendez je vais vous donner
complètement ma stratégie énergétique si
vous me laissez deux secondes allez pour
continuer parce qu'après il y a les
pratiques mais sur les sur les centrales
thermiques on en avait 4
on voulait toutes les fermer on a
quasiment on pouvait toutes les fermer
c'est charbon là
on ne peut pas aller jusqu'au bout
pourquoi parce qu'on a pris du retard
sur l'ouverture de le père de
Flamanville et donc non mais c'est ça la
réalité oui et donc et donc pour
maintenir et pas être en black out et en
hiver on a dû en maintenir une en
activité partielle mais on va aller au
bout je tiendrai mon engagement ensuite
sur les renouvelables vous avez
totalement raison le chiffre est très
juste le problème qu'on a sur le
renouvelable c'est que nous on a lancé
pas mal de projets et je veux continuer
c'est dans ma stratégie mais les projets
sont beaucoup trop lents moi j'ai
inauguré le premier projet d'éolienne en
mer en Bretagne il avait été lancé sous
Nicolas Sarkozy donc c'est ça la réalité
c'est qu'on on met aujourd'hui plus de 8
ans à faire des projets donc en effet la
France est un des pays qui est le plus
en retard sur les EnR donc là on a
commencé tes proportionnelle c'est à
dire que mais bien sûr mais là dessus on
doit aller beaucoup plus vite c'est dans
ma stratégie je vais venir 60% par
exemple et donc on doit aller beaucoup
plus vite même si fait du nucléaire et
en même temps c'est aussi pour ça que je
le fais en début d'année en début de
mandat s'il est française et les
Français me font confiance il faut qu'on
ait une loi de simplification pour
réduire les délais maintenant j'explique
le mix le mix énergétique parce que
c'est le cœur non mais esprit de
synthèse esprit de synthèse toujours
c'est clé si on veut faire des économies
moins émettre il faut en faire je
reprends le mot j'en ai plein champ que
j'ai critiqué à l'instant une
planification énergétique parce qu'en
effet comme ça que ça peut marcher
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire il y a trois
piliers dans cette planification pilier
1 sobriété ah on doit moins consommer de
manière intelligente là-dessus pour
répondre à Madame j'ai un bilan
la sobriété c'est rénover les bâtiments
pour qu'on chauffe moins en 2021 grâce à
la prime rénov on a rénové 650 000
logements mon objectif c'est fort de ce
bilan parce que on savait pas bien le
faire avant on a beaucoup changé les
choses on a fait un énorme boulot les
élus de terrain le savent les élus de
terrain savent on a fait un c'est
compliqué oui mais on a fait un boulot
avec l'agence nationale et en lien avec
les élus de terrain et donc dans les 5
ans qui viennent je veux rénover au
moins 700 000 logements par an ça c'est
un énorme levier de sobriété deuxième
levier de sobriété l'électrification de
notre mobilité c'est-à-dire sortir des
vieux véhicules pour aller vers les
véhicules dernière génération en
particulier électrique durant ce
quinquennat j'ai nous avons parce que
c'est notre argent à tous accompagner un
million de nos compatriotes pour changer
de véhicule
c'est du gain de pouvoir d'achat et
c'est de la sobriété ça on continue ça
on va continuer je veux même renforcer
en mettant en place un système de
leasing pour le véhicule électrique que
vous puissiez parce que on parlait de
pouvoir d'achat un couple qui est au
SMIC ne peut pas s'acheter un véhicule
électrique aujourd'hui malgré nos aides
le reste à charge est trop importante et
donc je veux mettre en place avec un
système de garantie un système où vous
paierez moins de 100 euros par mois et
donc très vite grâce aux économies sur
les plains votre véhicule et les
croisières et en développant non non ça
c'est toujours sur la sobriété en
développant en développant une filière
française parce que derrière c'est créer
de l'emploi je veux de créer une filière
française de l'éolien on est en train de
le faire au Havre et ailleurs je veux
créer une filière française de véhicules
électriques on a créé ce moment-là 3
giga Factory de batterie électrique il y
en avait 0 quand j'ai été élu tout ça
c'est des mécanismes de sobriété et puis
de continuer le transport doux on a fait
je crois de mémoire 13000 km avec les
collectivités de pistes de vélo mais ce
que clairement c'est suffisant on a le
Haut Conseil pour le climat un organe
gouvernemental d'experts indépendants
très effets de c'est en France et bien
trop long il faudra les deux à trois
fois plus vite si on veut exactement là
je vous dis sur la sobriété vous avez
compris voilà ce que j'ai fait voilà ce
que je veux faire donc j'ai réussi à le
faire sur les deux dernières années là
si je le fais sur 50 j'aurais deux fois
plus d'efficacité et je veux continuer
sur le volet sobriété le vélo les
transports urbains l'électrification
l'hydrogène dans les transports urbains
et l'aide aux collectivités premier
volet sobriété deuxième pilier c'est
hyper important il y a plein de choses
importantes après le climat il y en a
tellement peuple
donc deuxième point pour réduire les gaz
à effet de serre c'est développer le
renouvelable là on a commencé on n'a pas
été super bon jusqu'au bout et donc je
veux une loi de simplification pour
réduire les délais qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire on doit aller beaucoup plus vite
sur le photovoltaïque et là on a un
levier formidable c'est
l'agricoltaïs nos agriculteurs si on
veut les aider à avoir un complément de
revenu faut permettre de déployer et on
est en train de finaliser les cahiers
des charges justement des panneaux
solaires on a de l'emprise foncière de
l'état de la SNCF mais on veut déployer
du soleil et j'ai un objectif de 40
gigas en éolien offshore on sait
maintenant beaucoup mieux concerté avec
les pêcheurs avec la biodiversité non
mais c'est un super projet on est la
deuxième puissance maritime du monde et
l'éolien offshore est un formidable
levier et maintenant c'est rentable je
veux dire il y a 5 ans elle était
beaucoup moins c'est rentable donc le
deuxième pilier vraie stratégie
renouvelable mais cette stratégie elle
permet si on arrive à faire d'avoir de
l'électricité mais elle ne permet pas de
remplacer notre notre parc nucléaire
pourquoi c'est très important tout le
monde le comprenne parce que c'est
intermittent le renouvelable et ça ne
permet de produire de l'électricité en
plus mais ça ne me permet pas de
remplacer mon parc actuel et puis mon
troisième pilier c'est le nucléaire
c'est hyper important et pourquoi il
faut en faire parce que ça RTE je vous
renvoie à leur rapport avec les lieux
ils l'ont montré même si je fais de
l'effort en sobriété et même si je
réduis de 30% ma consommation
d'électricité actuelle grâce à mes
efforts de sobriété
la transition énergétique du pays
la baisse de mes émissions de gaz à
effet de serre elle passe par
l'électrification des pratiques alors on
a une question
si je veux passer du véhicule thermique
au véhicule électrique j'ai besoin de
produire plus d'électricité et d'avoir
des bornes si je veux remplacer mon gaz
que j'importe de Russie j'apporte du
Qatar et ailleurs mon gaz naturel qui
est une énergie aussi où mon essence que
j'importe dans mon nucléaire j'emporte
pas cette uranium un peu quand même
j'importe mais je le sécurise et grâce à
mes innovations je veux de plus en plus
fermer le site alors mais beaucoup moins
non non mais si je veux remplacer ce gaz
là par de l'hydrogène l'hydrogène le
produit par de l'électrolyse
l'électrolyse a besoin d'électricité et
donc beaucoup d'électricité et donc de
toute façon à 2050 si je fais -30% de
consommation électrique mais que
j'électrifie mes usages j'aurais besoin
de produire environ 50% d'électricité en
plus c'est pour ça que mon troisième
pilier c'est le nucléaire et j'ai besoin
de 6 nouvelle que j'ai déjà décidé mais
elle commencera en 2025 Emmanuel Macron
ce projet non mais ce projet sobriété
renouvelable nucléaire d'accord et le
seul projet je dis bien et on va plus
revenir sur Leclerc juste après c'est le
seul projet crédible qui permet de faire
avancer des énergies fossiles et de
notre dépendance alors les autres vous
laissent dans la dépendance on continue
à parler au sens très large de
l'écologie et de la nature avec une
question ça vous surprendra peut-être
sur la chasse
la chasse est une véritable barbarie
malgré plusieurs sondages montrant que
les Français françaises sont favorables
à l'interdiction il ne s'est rien passé
durant votre précédent quinquennat quel
est votre position actuelle
moi je pense qu'il faut toujours peser
les mots et je dirais pas que la chasse
est une barbarie la chasse c'est une
pratique ça envoie aussi à des
traditions il y a des chasses qui sont
plus acceptables et moi j'ai d'ailleurs
assumé de les arrêter le Conseil d'État
aussi non ce fin ça a été une décision
de votre serviteur le Conseil d'État il
a interdit sur certaines espèces
et on pourrait revenir pas la chasse à
courre alors
c'est un vrai débat la chasse à courre
c'est pas une barbarie c'est honnêtement
c'est tu trouves une pratique désuète et
plutôt assez c'est plutôt des gens très
aisés qui le font c'est pas la majorité
de
la majorité non non mais je pense que
moi je suis plutôt pour l'interdire non
je vais vous dire surtout ça franchement
très franchement surtout ces sujets on
peut décider la politique du clash
permanent et les gens adorent bon moi je
suis plutôt pour le pragmatisme essayez
d'avancer il y a des millions de nos
compatriotes qui chassent
ce sont des gens qui aiment la nature et
la ruralité autant que vous et moi
autant que ceux qui disent que c'est la
barbarie et d'ailleurs très souvent ce
sont des gens qui vivent plus dans la
nature que toute celles et ceux qui leur
donnent des leçons
parce que ils vivent avec leur chien ils
vivent très souvent dans la campagne
avec des promeneurs qui parfois ont peur
d'eux ok mais ça c'est des conflits
d'usage donc ça ça se régule mais ça se
régule pas tant que ça parce qu'il y a
énormément de blessé chaque année mais
il y a plein de personnes j'ai peur de
me balader en forêt parce que donc ça
c'est pour ça qu'il y a des règles et
qu'à chaque fois il faut et donc ça ça
se discute au niveau d'un territoire le
maire est d'ailleurs là pour ça les
gardes champêtres l'office français et
donc il faut faire du cas par cas mais
bien sûr qu'il faut réguler et aussi
beaucoup plus contrôler ce qu'on a fait
donc qu'est-ce que j'ai fait moi j'ai
dit au chasseur j'assume totalement moi
je suis pas contre les chasseurs je suis
pour qu'on ait une politique certains
diront vous serez même plutôt pour
non je suis pour une politique sincère
et constructive de gestion de la
biodiversité et de la ruralité eux ils
sont pour vous la Fédération
n'a appelé pour vous dès le premier tour
est-ce que c'est un boulet quand on veut
apparaître comme plutôt écolo non parce
que j'assume totalement et j'ai pas
franchement qui est des gens qui se
prononcent de manière nette pour vous
soutenir je vais pas leur dire que c'est
un mauvais choix mais moi j'assume ce
choix mais j'assume un choix aussi pour
le bien-être animal surtout les sujets
moi je vais au-delà de la chasse mais je
vais au bout sur la chasse un la chasse
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a dit arrêtons
le face à face on met tout le monde
autour de la table on a créé l'office
français pour la biodiversité c'était un
rêve de tous les écologistes depuis des
décennies quel est le résultat de ça on
met les gens autour de la table chasseur
environnement
environnementaliste ONG spécialiste et
on dit espace par espèces on regarde ce
qui peut être chassé ce qui ne peut pas
être chassé ce qui est la règle
habituelle non c'est faux la règle
habituelle était administrative non non
la règle était administrative donc il y
avait des confrontations permanentes et
on avait des autorisations en fait du
coup on ne suivait pas bien les espèces
et donc il y avait des autorisations
absolues et à l'inverse il y avait des
espèces qui commençaient à être
fragilisées qu'on interdisait pas et
donc là grâce à l'OSB qui est vraiment
une innovation où il y a tout le monde
autour de la table et moi je veux qu'ils
apprennent à se parler tout ces gens
c'est ça mon but et bien chaque année on
regarde et on dit est-ce que la
tourterelle des bois le tetraz est-ce
que ils sont en non mais est-ce qu'ils
ont en danger ou pas quels sont les
quotas est-ce qu'on peut les chasser ou
pas je dis pas que c'est pacifique qui
s'engueulent pas mais au moins il se
parle et on crée une culture commune
ensuite
on doit le faire mais ça marche pas
forcément mais on peut pas on peut pas
dire il y a des millions de gens dont
c'est parfois l'équilibre de vie les
traditions l'identité ces millions de
gens moi ils m'intéresse pas si pardon
mais en tant que président de la
République et candidat pour le devenir
c'est mon devoir d'essayer de réunir
tout le monde et je crois que c'est bon
pour tout le monde et pour la communauté
interdit des chasses parce que les mêmes
qui me soutiennent aujourd'hui mais la
chasse à la glue j'aurais dit c'est une
pratique alors on peut pas continuer
là-dessus on a interdite alors justement
la cause animale j'ai fait plein de
choses suivantes c'est la question
suivante elle est là tout de suite
monsieur Macron 5 ans après votre prise
de pouvoir aucune mesure n'a été prise
contre le fléau de Eva intensif
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi cette mesure
qui est un point essentielle de la
transition écologique ne figure toujours
pas dans votre programme élevage
intensif moins sur d'ailleurs la
question de la souffrance animale que
sur la question écologique les deux posé
comme ça d'abord faut regarder tout ça
c'est un changement de modèle de
consommation et de production moi je dis
la même chose sur nos éleveurs et nos
chasseurs parce que je suis pas là pour
être démago
les éleveurs ce sont des des femmes et
des hommes qui ne savent pas ce que
c'est qu'un jour férié il y a pas de
week-end il y a pas de jours férié
non mais pardon c'est pas forcément le
sujet là le sujet c'est de se dire
par exemple qui nous montre ce qui se
passe dans des élevages intensifs avec
des poules qui sont dans des cages par
dizaines parfois par centaines c'est
finalement des associations qui révèlent
ça salarié
ou les patrons mais quel que soit les
modèles
là-dessus je vais quand même défendre le
monde agricole quel qu'il soit non mais
première chance ce sont des gens qui
vivent avec leurs animaux et qui signent
les aimaient pas seraient pas c'est pas
éleveur objectivement quand je regarde
le modèle français il est beaucoup moins
intensif que tous nos voisins là aussi
comparent en nous et regardons ce qu'on
mange
pardon regardons ce qu'on mange et ce
qu'on veut faire donc moi je veux bien
qu'on se dise tout de suite à nos
agriculteurs qui ont des modèles
familiaux pour beaucoup parce que c'est
la force du modèle ça la question donc
je vais venir mais je pars oui mais
c'est hyper important je suis pareil je
suis pas dans le raccourci parce que je
veux pas stigmatiser je veux pas opposer
l'idée de stigmatiser
ça fait des années qu'on dit on veut
bouffer moins cher et donc on bouffe de
la merde pardon de dire ça comme ça
qu'on importe d'élevage intensif de
reste de l'Europe et que on stigmatise
les agriculteurs qui sont chez nous et
on leur permet pas de vivre de leurs
revenus un éleveur en France en moyenne
et touche 300 euros par an mais faut
qu'on arrête de faire du face à face
mais là c'est pas possible mais si il y
en a aussi dans ton diction intensifs
vous avez des éleveurs qui ont des
petits modèles qui parfois ne peuvent
pas investir et dans lesquels des
associations qui veulent le bien-être
animal que je respecte des boules et les
stigmatises on pourra mettre des faits
qui sont quand même implacables les
images elles sont pas inventées quelque
chose on ne pourra pas avancer sont des
questions français publique aussi mais
oui mais on avancera pas si on fait du
face à face c'est important d'avoir la
réalité tout de même mais je la vois
totalement autant que vous de tous les
côtés et concrètement comment on fait
pour que ça non plus concrètement il
faut investir bouger mettre des Caps ce
qu'on a commencé à faire est-ce qu'on va
continuer donc 1 on doit bouger le
modèle européen pour que partout en
Europe on sort de l'intensif qui Bafou
la condition animale c'est ce qu'on fait
c'est ce qu'on pousse et c'est ce qu'on
a fait dans la PAC qui pour la première
fois a des normes sur ce volet là donc
premier point parce que non mais on peut
pas s'en sortir tout seul si les copains
continuent à produire comme ça autour de
nous on va tuer notre agriculture avec
lesquels on a des accords de
libre-échange le font mais moi je suis
contre je me suis opposé au Mercosur
donc le Canada mais le CETA n'a pas du
tout les mêmes modèles et il s'éteint en
a mis un véto climatique et sur beaucoup
de ces sujets de la même manière non
pardon on a eu un boulot d'un an qui
doit d'ailleurs beaucoup à nos
parlementaires et à Nicolas Hulot pour
pour réguler ce qui avait été fait mais
quand je regarde les choses c'est pour
ça moi je me suis opposé au Mercosur sur
cette raison
donc et moi je suis pour des clauses
miroirs sur le modèle agricole donc la
France par notre voie pour la première
fois à poser justement un système de
clause miroir qui est de dire ce qu'on
contraint à nos éleveurs de fer on le
demande aux éleveurs de chez qui on
importe mais en européen on doit bouger
ensemble deuxième chose c'est pour ça
que je vous m'entendais les défendre
parce que ce serait plus facile pour moi
devant vous de évidemment de dire je
parle qu'à celles et ceux qui
s'indignent je veux parler à tout le
monde parce que c'est trop facile il y a
des modèles intensifs qui jouent pas le
jeu on leur a mis des contraintes on a
commencé sur les élevages en batterie je
les fais il y a 5 ans sur les poules
pondeuses on a commencé à mettre des
contraintes pour réformer et on les a
accompagnés parce que la vérité il faut
accompagner les filières pour investir
et pour quelle sorte de ces modèles et
prendre en compte le bien-être animal
donc on a investi sur justement les
modèles pour que on ait des modèles
d'élevage en plein air qu'on va
progressivement généraliser mais faut
les aider ce qu'on fait deuxième point
il y avait un sujet terrible sur les
élevages intensifs qui étaient le
broyage de Poussin parce que comme vous
le savez on ne savait passer désormais
interdit on a interdit mais pourquoi la
même manière il y a 5 ans quand on me le
demandait je me faisais conspire parce
que vous êtes vous aimez pas la cause
animale vous l'interdisez pas je me suis
fait engueuler par Brigitte Bardot et
d'autres parce que
bon c'est tout elle défend avec beaucoup
de sincérité je me suis fait engueuler
par Brigitte Bardot Bardot parfois je me
fais aussi engueuler par la mienne mais
pas sur ce sujet mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a dit on peut
pas interdire c'est impossible on a mis
de l'argent dans la recherche et
l'investissement on a réussi par la
génétique on a fait un gros projet
franco-allemand et maintenant on sait
déterminé le sexe je vais pas rentrer
dans la technique et donc on a plus
besoin de les broyer et donc on investit
on permet aux éleveurs de le faire plus
de voyage alors on avance pareil non
mais on avance il y avait de la
castration des jeunes
ça m'intéresse c'est de voir pas mal de
sujets différents donc on va devoir
avancer donc ce que j'aurais une autre
question pour moi un d'abord j'ai un
bilan sur le sujet de
l'élevage
on va continuer ce que je veux vous
faire comprendre c'est que on doit avoir
un agenda de solution et pas de
stigmatisation d'investissement pour
accompagner et d'exigence et donc on va
continuer et honnêtement toutes les Asos
font un boulot hyper important ce que je
voudrais c'est qu'on arrive à mieux
coopérer pour que elle fasse aussi un
travail qui parfois
traumatise moi nos éleveurs et les
mettre moins en face à face elle nous
aide qu'elle dénonce mais sans rentrer
dans les élevages et qu'à ce moment là
on aide on investissement accompagné
qui est trop baptise aussi des gens
c'est on revient sur le nucléaire avec
une question très particulière qui vous
est posée à l'instant
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire des
déchets nucléaires est-ce que vous allez
juste les léguer aux générations futures
alors c'est un sujet très important donc
on a un projet d'enfouissement il y en a
certains donc il y a un cycle qui est
compliqué il y a des parties de
retraitement là tout ce qui s'appelle le
cyclaval sur lequel on a des acteurs
nucléaires
les déchets comme justement un eau et
d'autres et c'est une compétence qu'on a
et sur les déchets on a une stratégie
d'enfouissement des déchets qu'on
n'arrive plus à résoudre c'est un projet
qui durait depuis des années on l'a
défendu et on prendra d'ailleurs les
textes qu'il faut là dans les prochaines
semaines c'est donc l'enfouissement
c'est le projet cigaux à Bure qui
permettra de répondre à ce sujet ça
c'est le plus ça session du coin quand
elles sont interrogées sont plutôt
défavorables à l'enfouissement des bases
qui sont contre tous les élus sont pour
tous les élus locaux parce que ça fait
aussi beaucoup de mes revenus mais oui
parce qu'il faut compenser les choses
après faut qu'il y ait une sûreté il
faut qu'il y ait une transparence
démocratique complète un accompagnement
donc c'est ce qu'on fait la loi la
prévue il y a un suivi il y aura des
mesures donc il y a pas non mais il y a
pas de miracle faut pas les faut pas le
Léguer dans de mauvaises conditions
comme vous le dites aux générations
futures mais il est il n'empêche que ce
faisant ça nous permet de ne pas léguer
des gaz à des gaz à l'émission des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre merci
de m'aider à nos générations futures et
c'est malgré tout mieux ça c'est le
premier réponse sur ce dont on hérite et
ce qu'on produit après moi j'ai voulu
réinvestir sur ce qu'on appelle la
fermeture du cycle c'est-à-dire produire
moins de déchet le nucléaire de demain
ne peut pas être un nucléaire qui
produit autant de déchets si on veut le
développer et donc c'est des normes
sujets c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on
puisse aller vers d'autres techniques la
technique du laser la technique
il y a fusion efficion sur lesquelles on
doit continuer à avancer et puisqu'on
appelle la fermeture du cycle qui permet
de réutiliser et qui est hyper important
parce qu'elle permet de réduire le
besoin d'un train et nos dépendances à
certains et leur recyclage
et ça c'est en particulier sur ce qu'on
appelle les SMR modular reactor un des
points clés parce que il y a beaucoup
moins de déchets etc avancer sur un
sujet tout aussi important c'est la
santé mentale et on va tout de suite
écouter la question de Colombes bonjour
monsieur Macron comptez-vous du roman
faire des réformes ayant pour obliger la
santé mentale et notamment la prise en
charge du burn out telle maladie
professionnelle
alors la santé mentale est un immense
sujet
et pour moi c'est un des sujets
d'assumer je l'ai dit je crois quand
j'ai présenté mon programme et je l'ai
redis d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours
quand j'ai fait un meeting sur lequel je
veux
absolument m'investir
durant la crise covid on a tous vécu
ensemble on a parlé on a vu ce sujet
émerger chez les jeunes et donc c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs pour la première fois
qu'on a mis en place le chèque psy et je
dis pas ça comme d'ailleurs un succès
mais je regardais là aussi en venant les
chiffres qui sont impressionnants
sincèrement de nombre de chèques psy qui
ont été utilisés et qui montrent la
détresse qui a eu évidemment pas les
retrouver comme ça
c'est bien collectivement qu'on les ai
accompagnés parce que je pense que c'est
gratuit c'est mieux que ce qui existait
avant mais c'est terrible de se dire que
nous avons bon c'est pas grave comme je
suis comme d'habitude j'apprends tout
par coeur voilà il y a eu 237 000 chepsi
qui ont été utilisés 237 000 durant la
crise covid donc ça vous montre le
besoin qu'il y avait 237
000 pardon jeunes qui l'ont utilisé donc
là c'était les accompagnement ensuite
j'ai décidé on a lancé un santé mentale
durant ce quinquennat il y a quelques
mois je l'ai conclu ce travail qui a été
fait qui a permis de d'abord revaloriser
ces professions reconnaître le travail
des psychiatres mais aussi des
psychologues de tous les cliniciens de
ville on a un besoin de continuer à le
développer à l'hôpital elle est
également en ville à l'école de détecter
et d'accompagner et donc c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a mis en place un forfait
pour accompagner avant la psychiatrie le
chèque psyl et reconnaître dans un
parcours de soins le travail des
psychologues
je pense d'abord en parler est très
important et en parler le détecter le
plus tôt possible et très important donc
c'est pour ça que 1 on va continuer ce
qu'on a commencé c'est à dire la
détection
dès le plus jeune âge en particulier à
l'entrée aux primaires des différents
troubles dont les troubles
psychiatriques chez les plus jeunes on a
fait
le détection de toutes les formes
d'autisme des différentes formes de 10
mais il y a avec ça la souffrance
mentale chez les plus petits ensuite je
veux qu'on puisse améliorer si un des
grands chantiers pour l'école la
médecine scolaire et l'accompagnement
justement psy au lycée et dans les
études je me permets de vous couper la
question portée aussi très clairement
sur le bord et après c'est le monde du
travail et donc sur le monde du travail
là sur la question du burn out il faut
maintenant qu'on arrive à la qualifier
et donc ça c'est un travail qui doit
faire avec les psychiatres parce que la
question du burn out tant qu'on telle
qu'on la pose est toujours fait se
distinguer il y a la question si je puis
dire sociétale je suis mal dans ma vie
tout là est-ce que c'est forcément une
maladie professionnelle il y a la
question après si au travail il y a
vraiment quelque chose et qui a un
effondrement qui est lié aux conditions
ce qui est très lié d'ailleurs parfois
aussi aux problèmes du harcèlement au
travail
qui est un vrai sujet là il faut qu'on
puisse se qualifier avec des psychiatres
avec la médecine du travail donc pour
moi c'est un ensemble donc oui il faut
qu'on avance sur ce sujet oui il faut le
faire en lien et qualifier très
précisément mais pour moi la santé
mentale est un sujet au-delà du burn out
qui sur lequel on a on a levé le voile
ces derniers ces derniers mois ces
dernières années ensemble et je pense
qu'il faut pas le alors tomber question
suivante qui va arriver tout de suite
justement sur le Ségur de la santé qui
était un point important et qui va
s'afficher tout de suite
bonjour monsieur le Président je
m'appelle Emmanuel je suis infirmier
depuis 14 ans dans un hôpital public à
Bordeaux malgré le secure l'hôpital ne
va pas mieux les soignants partent
massivement des services de soins
première question dans votre programme
vous mentionnez que vous souhaitez
recruter des soignants comment
comptez-vous vous y prendre et ensuite
comptez-vous valoriser nos salaires qui
y restent en deçà de la moyenne
européenne merci
alors je ne sais pas quel est la
spécialité le service dans lequel est
Monsieur
d'ailleurs de Bordeaux nous renvoie au
coût de la vie dans les villes tout à
l'heure le Ségur de la santé c'est un
investissement historique en termes de
rémunération de tous les personnels
soignants mais ça infirmier infirmière
aide-soignante et ensuite on a étendu
aux EHPAD omédico-social au total il y a
2 millions de travailleuses et
travailleurs dans les métiers du soin
qui ont été revalorisés sont pas des
primes ponctuelles c'est une
revalorisation qui durera et qui
continuera dans la carrière le minimum
de revalo c'est 184 euros par mois à
mettre en perspective parce que la
France était aussi à la traîne par
rapport depuis des années 60 on n'avait
jamais fait ça 184 euros par mois je le
dis aussi parce que c'est je défends mon
bilan et j'en suis fier mais en contexte
aussi de dire qu'il y a un retard énorme
oui et ça va jusqu'à 480 euros par mois
pour certaines professions et
spécialités bon premier point pourquoi
juste pourquoi a-t-il fallu une crise
sanitaire d'une telle ampleur et qu'on
applaudisse les infirmiers à 20h pour
que ça se débloque d'abord on n'a pas
découvert ça normal mais moi j'assume
d'avoir mis en place dès 2018 une
stratégie pour la santé qui pour la
première 19 la moitié des services
d'urgence était en grève non mais pour
la première fois de pas tout à fait la
moitié mais il y avait une vraie grève
non mais une vraie grève une fois que
parce que en fait encore présente le
plan qu'on avait décidé est arrivé
presque trop tard mais pardon j'ai été
lu en 2017 je fais lui en 2017 en 2018
je lance un plan qui s'appelle ma santé
2022 je mets fin à la baisse du tarif
hospitalier qui existait depuis 15 ans
je dis on va sortir de la tarification à
l'activité je mets en place la politique
de prévention renforcée et je dis on
réinvestit dans l'hôpital simplement
c'était pas assez l'hôpital était déjà
en souffrance était trop loin de la
fermer beaucoup de lit depuis mais pour
non mais pardon ce sujet de fermeture de
lit je veux me défendre là-dessus allez
c'est pas vrai qu'on ferme des lits
c'est qu'en fait on n'arrive plus à
recruter et c'est lié à quoi c'est lié
au fait qu'on avait trop contraint les
formations et ensuite qui a même des
gens quand on réforme qui ont abandonné
et donc c'est un problème c'est pas un
problème très faible des conditions de
travail mais donc attendez
je vous laisse répondre mais depuis un
an malgré le Ségur on a deux en moyenne
de départ par établissement de santé
immense fatigue et une perte de sens du
boulot c'est pas que de l'argent non
c'est exactement mon point c'est pour ça
que je veux changer de méthode sur la
réforme et sur l'école d'abord c'est de
l'argent ça a changé la vie dans
beaucoup d'hôpital il y a des tas
d'hôpitaux ou des soignants vous disent
merci ça va beaucoup mieux à Bordeaux le
coup de la vie à flambé depuis qu'elle
TGV donc c'est pas de hasard si c'était
une des villes où il y avait des gilets
jaunes les plus revendicatifs et donc à
Bordeaux ce qui est vrai c'est que si on
est infirmé à Bordeaux malgré
l'augmentation si on se replace avec 5
10 ans de perspective on vit pas mieux
parce que le coût de la vie a beaucoup
augmenté se loger est très cher donc ça
c'est une réalité et c'est vrai c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un sujet grande ville
ou de la vie flambe et là où il faut
qu'on pense logement des personnels
soignants avec les collectivités
publiques je ferme cette parenthèse
pour comprendre la problématique quand
on vit après quel est le problème 1 il
faut former plus donc quand je dis je
vais en embaucher je vais en forme et on
a ouvert sur les médecins les aides
soignants les infirmiers les médecins
malheureusement j'ai décidé l'ouverture
2018 qui ont accéléré je verrai pas même
si les Françaises et les Français me
font confiance ils n'arriveront pas à
s'installer avant la fin du prochain
quinquennat
donc il va falloir mieux utiliser le
temps médical dont on dispose mieux
orienter avec une vraie révolution
culturelle que je propose dans mon
programme je peux le détailler 2 oui on
va former beaucoup plus d'infirmiers
infirmières et de soignants et soignants
ça on a ouvert des postes et derrière on
veut continuer de valoriser le salaire
en reconnaissant les professions
reconnaissant les spécialités 3 un des
points moi j'ai été frappé beaucoup
d'infirmiers infirmières me l'ont dit
quand il faisait des spécialités qu'il
changeait dans leur quartier qui
évoluaient c'était pas reconnu en termes
de responsabilité de salaire ça je veux
qu'on le change on a commencé avec les
ibots et on va continuer 4 moi je veux
la révolution culturelle de
l'organisation à l'hôpital et entre
l'hôpital et David pourquoi beaucoup de
gens partent je fais le constat comme
vous et les cruelles ce qui c'est pas
qu'une question d'argent c'est une
question de sens d'organisation du
boulot et donc non mais dans le moi
j'avais été frappé j'ai fait beaucoup
d'hôpitaux à la fin du premier
confinement ça avait été terrible
il y avait une forme de d'espoir c'est
là que j'ai décidé de le Ségur il y
avait une espoir en disant on a fait des
choses incroyables on pensait que
c'était pas possible et en fait cet
espoir ensuite a été déçu la part
rémunération elle a été au rendez-vous
même au-delà de ce que certains
demandaient ce qu'on a pas réussi à
faire c'est changer la culture et
l'organisation
c'est collectivement pourquoi parce
qu'en fait quand on reste avec les mêmes
structures et que tout est décidé d'en
haut ça marche pas et en fait qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé pendant la crise les
soignants c'était de l'organisation de
guerre pardon de le dire en ces termes
et donc d'un seul coup il y avait plus
d'autorisation à demander pour avoir tel
ou telle équipements pour recruter de
telles choses on n'avait plus de remplir
des circulaires on attendait plus trois
mois on se serrer les coudes les
administratifs étaient côte à côte avec
les soignants et on était dans des
logiques projets on retrouvait du sens
et l'organisation actuelle de l'hôpital
est plus généralement notre médecine a
fait que on a collectivement c'est la
faute de personnes c'est la faute du
système donc faut le changer le sens a
été perdu et donc je veux et c'est un
peu le risque c'est qu'on est la même
chose du côté de l'éducation donc moi
c'est aussi pour ça que je veux qu'on
puisse redonner de la responsabilité sur
un territoire décloisonner beaucoup
l'hôpital et la ville et dire au fond
l'administratif doit être au service de
la projet de santé publique à l'instant
quelques questions courtes réponses
rapides on sait que il y a quelques
semaines le port du masque a été levé
dans les lieux clos il est encore
obligatoire dans les transports tout
simplement à quand ça lever avant la fin
du quinquennat ou s'il fait si vous êtes
élu à partir de quand il faut être
pragmatique comme on était à chaque fois
protégé de manière proportionnelle et
pragmatique on l'a laissé dans les
transports en commun parce que vous avez
vu ça continue à monter là je pense
qu'on est voilà on a on a passé le pic
donc ça baisse si la baisse se confirme
il y a un moment donné on va lever mais
ce que vous avez une date Suisse par
exemple ont pris la décision ils ont
constaté qu'il y avait une baisse ils
ont dit voilà on l'enlève
concrètement s'il y avait un horizon
vous a donné un horizon pour le masque
le regarder avec honnêtement à chaque
fois les modèles j'ai d'abord je veux
qu'on ait une vraie consolidation parler
de l'hôpital vous savez ce serait quoi
un taux d'incidence je veux un que ça
baisse vraiment dans la durée et deux
que on sorte de la pression sur
l'hôpital parce que l'hôpital la
pression elle n'a pas ça n'a pas formé
c'est pour ça qu'on a pas remis le pas
c'est autre mais faut juste qu'on peut
imaginer être l'été prochain dans un
train sans masque oui je pense que c'est
raisonnable
mais je le dis c'est hyper important
quand on parle de l'hôpital pourquoi il
y a aussi cette fatigue il y a la perte
de sens etc mais faut pas oublier un
truc ça fait deux ans que nos
professionnels de santé ils ont jamais
arrêté parce que non nous on a connu les
pics le stress mais quand les pics
arrêtés en fait eux ils reprogrammaient
les soins qui avaient été décalés et
donc ils ont travaillé d'arrache-pied on
a dû demander à des maîtres on a pu
demander à des médecins des infirmières
des infirmières de reprogrammer de
parfois d'annuler leurs vacances même
quand il y avait plus de pics d'épidémie
que nous on était tous heureux en disant
il y a plus le pic eux ils rebossait
pour reprogrammer la question du passe
vaccinal vous avez dit qu'il est
suspendu c'est un terme pas anodin
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il peut
remonter enfin qui peut reprendre mais
ça veut dire que je suis très
pragmatique là je vais être très précis
la loi a donné la possibilité au
gouvernement de l'utiliser jusqu'en
juillet
et donc si il y avait à nouveau une
flambée d'épidémie ton incidence c'est
quoi parce que c'est souvent des
chiffres d'incidences lis vous avez des
raisons faut pas c'est pas que le taux
d'incidence s'il y avait une remontée
très forte qui s'accompagnait d'une
montée de l'hôpital et des soins
critiques qui fait qu'à nouveau on
passait le seuil critique de plus de
2000 chiffres bah non mais si dans les
soins critiques on repasse à un niveau
qui doit conduire à la déprogrammation
pour moi c'est ça le caca quand on passe
en soins critique à un niveau où on
déprogrammes je vais être concret il
faut pas se donner s'interdire de
réutiliser le Pass sanitaire et le passe
vaccinal pourquoi parce que on s'est
d'abord on sait qu'on peut l'utiliser
que c'est pas honnêtement une entrave
disproportionnée
mais quand on dit on doit déprogrammer
des soins on dit juste que votre frère
ou votre sœur qui peut être un cancer
qui avait une opération qu'il attendait
depuis des mois on va lui dire on peut
pas la faire là on la fera dans 6 mois
et on lui enlève des espérances c'est ça
la réalité c'est ça ce qui s'est passé
pendant la crise il faut être honnête on
l'a fait pendant la crise opérations
vitales tout de même mais quand on
déprogramme on commence par les
opérations de confort mais ensuite oui
nous avons pardon mais les soignants
l'ont dit et a raison je le dis pour que
tout le monde s'en rende compte nous
avons aussi été conduits dans les
déprogrammations à prendre des choix qui
ont été très durs ils l'ont été par des
soignants mais donc ça n'est pas anodin
Emmanuel Macron simplement je veux
rassurer tout le monde
bonjour monsieur Macron l'égalité
homme-femme devait être la grande cause
votre quinquennat aujourd'hui le nombre
de femicides ne diminue pas et cela
malgré que les associations féministes
et trouver
hétéros quelle réponse comptez-vous
apporter au féminisme et au combat
qu'elle porte
alors le nombre de féminicides
effectivement n'a pas diminué c'était la
grande cause du quinquennat vous avez
annoncé que ça serait la grande cause
d'un futur potentiel nouveau quinquennat
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ce jeune
homme je me mets
un féminicite c'est déjà trop donc je
vais pas rentrer dans une polémique de
chiffres même si avant ne les mesurait
pas et donc et maintenant les mesures
chaque jour mieux deux j'en ai fait la
grande cause il y a 5 ans je l'ai fait
avant MiTo et je l'ai fait parce que
justement dès octobre 2016 à l'issue de
la grande marche en particulier les
femmes qui avaient répondu à notre
grande enquête disait je ne suis pas
rassuré quand je prends les transports
il y a de l'insécurité il y a de la
violence
la grande cause avec une étudiante qui
donc la grande cause c'est l'égalité
salariale c'est les violences
intrafamiliales c'est le harcèlement de
rue tout ça où j'ai apporté des réponses
très concrètes sur les violences sur les
violences intrafamilales et donc les
féministes ce qu'on peut prendre très
concrètement le chiffre 509 bracelets
activés et il mesure prononcée 679 fois
par les tribunaux selon les chiffres du
ministère de la justice c'est très
faible par rapport au nombre de
violences conjugales
c'est dénoncer pour les associations
féministes comme étant pas à la hauteur
justement de ce qui se passe il faut il
faut continuer à poursuivre on a budgété
plus de 1000 bracelets donc ça veut dire
que tous les bracelets ne sont pas
utilisés mais c'est quoi son problème de
la justice du coup non mais c'est pas le
président de la République qui peut
intimer l'ordre un magistrat de la loi
qui peut aussi une loi possible mise en
place
le permet elle le fait mais la loi dans
notre loi c'est notre droit et c'est
constitutionnel la peine est
individualisée la loi ne peut pas dire
un juge qu'elle peine il doit donner
donc et d'ailleurs il faut s'en
satisfaire donc
je veux le sujet est immense très
important monsieur a parlé du milliard
oui on n'a jamais autant dépensé pour
lutter contre l'inégalité femme homme et
en particulier les violences que propose
Jean-Luc Mélenchon oui mais c'est pardon
mais c'est facile ces chiffres là parce
que on additionne des chevaux et des
fois
au maximum parce que c'est quoi mais non
mais en fait c'est pas du budget du
ministère d'égalité fameux c'est du
ministère de la Justice
la réalité mais d'ailleurs une fois
qu'on a cette discussion dans le détail
elle le concède puisque dès qu'on dit
regardez avec la ministre on a augmenté
ses budgets de manière historique le
ministère du budget n'a jamais été aussi
le ministère de l'Égalité femme n'a
jamais autant de budget et reste stable
non pardon monsieur je suis pas d'accord
avant les mesures et pas en prononcé
même pas le mot avant mesurer même pas
on prend et donc pour quelqu'un de
François Hollande les chiffres sont à
peu près stables on est
familiales 160 personnes qui perdent la
vie chaque année sous les coups de leurs
compagnons c'est un chiffre stable je
veux plus
répondre sur la question du budget
la réalité c'est de l'argent qu'on met
dans le budget de l'Intérieur et de la
justice sur ce sujet pas simplement dans
le budget de l'égalité famome or depuis
le début de mon quinquennat on a formé
des dizaines de milliers de policiers de
gendarmes pour instruire les plaintes
mais en parallèle on a encore des
personnes qui disent justement
est-ce que je considère que le problème
est réglé et que tout est satisfaisant
la réponse est non la réponse est NON je
veux simplement dire qu'est-ce qu'on a
changé quel résultat on a et qu'est-ce
que je veux intensifier on a un numéro
d'appel d'urgence qu'on a mis 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
avant il était à des horaires très
limités et ce qui permet aussi outre-mer
parce qu'on a très peu parlé d'outre-mer
jusqu'à lors mais nos compatriotes
d'outre-mer où il y a un énorme problème
de violence intrafamiliale peuvent
maintenant appeler cette plateforme 24
sur 24 19 deuxième chose on a mis en
place des points d'alerte parce que les
femmes nous est pas souvent le dire elle
n'allaient pas au commissariat et donc
on a mis dans les supermarchés dans les
pharmacies on a trouvé des partenaires
pour pouvoir dénoncer ces violences
troisième plan on a mis un plan la
souris s'il vous plaît mais c'est hyper
important
pour aider les associations et donc on a
développé leur budget elles le savent
très bien alors côté pour aider ces
femmes quatrième point on a formé les
policiers gendarmes qui très souvent
quand on a le commissariat oui oui
d'accord en main courante etc là pour
dire non vous devez prendre la plainte
on les a formés pour accueillir pour
recevoir la plainte pour instruire et
accélérer tous les sortants d'écoles de
police et gendarmerie aujourd'hui sont
formés sur le sujet des violences
intrafamiliales et des violences et des
féminicides 4 on a changé la loi
pour justement mettre en place des
téléphones graves dangers et donner aux
femmes qui sont menacées et avec la
possibilité de et les bracelets ils sont
aujourd'hui pas utilisés jusqu'à ce
qu'on malheureusement
bien sûr je suis pour qu'on les utilise
tous parce que si le problème était
réglé mais vous les chiffres que vous
dites nous le montrent bien et je les
connais donc il faut les utiliser au
maximum donc ça c'est une culture qu'il
faut changer pour que nos magistrats
utilisent au maximum le bracelet 4 après
il y a beaucoup de procureurs et de juge
qui ont aussi une politique qui est très
bonne qui est l'éloignement rapide du
conjoint violent parce qu'il faut pas se
tromper non plus très souvent ça marche
pas toujours non ça marche pas toujours
mais c'est hyper important c'est pour ça
que le bracelet est important parce que
le bracelet permet de dire interdiction
de paraître ça vous parlez de violence
mais il y a aussi la question du
harcèlement
faut aller plus loin c'est aussi les
foyers les logements l'accompagnement
des femmes quand on doit les honorer
parce que malheureusement pour moi la
solution la plus juste c'est alerte le
plus rapidement
et c'est dire celui qui doit partir
c'est celui qui est violent et donc
c'est là où le bracelet est utile le
juge très vite après comme vous l'avez
dit malheureusement ça ne va parfois pas
assez vite on peut pas le faire on doit
pouvoir très vite protéger la femme qui
est qui est frappée parfois la femme et
ses enfants et c'est là où avec les
associations on doit aller plus loin et
on doit créer plus de place de logement
pension de famille d'accompagnement
exact aussi la question du harcèlement
de rue et pardon donc le combat doit
continuer il n'est pas terminé j'aime
pas les chiffres magiques mais il faut
encore mettre de l'argent dans la
justice dans la police dans
l'hébergement
pour les réduire on a entendu que vous
étiez favor pour un milliard la question
suivante vous avez compris que le métier
dans plusieurs budgets exactement on a
compris et on va juste écouter la
question suivante d'une jeune étudiante
tout de suite
bonsoir Monsieur Macron je suis
étudiante j'ai 18 ans et parfois il
m'arrive de rentrer des cours assez tard
donc vers 20h 21h et il m'arrive aussi
assez souvent d'ailleurs d'être suivi
dans la rue d'être har d'être embêté par
des soit des garçons de mon âge ou des
hommes d'un certain âge et je voudrais
savoir vous Macron donc
réélu pour un second mandat consécutif
quelle mesure concrètes pourriez-vous
adopter pour
pour répondre à ça voilà
vous avez mis en place la loi en 2018
par rapport au harcèlement de rue le
résultat c'est 2% des victimes d'injures
sexistes qui portent plainte alors que 8
femmes sur 10 se 18ent vous dites très
bien la chose c'est qu'il faut pas qu'il
y ait d'autocensure ça marche pas alors
attendez je vais pas porter plainte à la
place des gens donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire le système en tout cas si nous
sommes sur 10 dis ça et qu'il y en a que
2 % qui portent plainte c'est qu'un
système d'abord qui n'est pas c'est
pratique le commentaire de Mademoiselle
le montre très bien manifestement il
n'est pas au courant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors donc premier point je vais
répondre le problème que je sais plus le
prénom de Mademoiselle qui était avec
nous mais moi je vais dire mademoiselle
le problème est un problème immense
je pense qu'on a été parmi avec en
marche les premiers vraiment le révéler
l'objectiver dans le champ politique à
l'époque champ médiatique me disait
d'accord si c'est son programme on peut
repasser c'est un vrai sujet donc pour
la première fois dans notre loi on a en
effet permis de mettre une amende quand
il y avait du harcèlement de rue et
jeune femme elle rentre chez elle et ben
non je veux le dire à toutes les jeunes
filles qui nous écoutent il y a en effet
maintenant une amende donc quand vous
avez du harcèlement de rue allez au
commissariat aller à la police prenez
tout de suite appel à témoin ça vraiment
les moyens aujourd'hui de discuter avec
des policiers dans des dans des
commissariats ils disent voilà on a une
un tas de feuilles qui est là on n'a pas
le temps de les traiter parce qu'on n'a
pas les moyens parce que justement il
faut le coup c'est les amandes c'est pas
des longues enquêtes et je vais venir
après sur les moyens et la police parce
que c'est un sujet qui est plus large
mais qui est hyper important qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire il y a deux trucs très
concrets par rapport à ce cet énorme
fluo enfin trois choses 1 le faire
savoir le faire savoir le faire savoir
cet amende existe n'acceptez pas ça
n'est pas autorisé c'est même puni donc
dé pouce bleu porter plainte deuxième
chose si je suis réélu je veux tripler
cette amende parce que ce qui va pas
qu'est-ce qui désinfitanise c'est pas
assez donc on va tripler troisième sujet
on va mettre plus de patrouille parce
que on a investi on a créé 10000 postes
de policiers gendarme et je vais aussi
qu'on les cible on va mettre des
brigades de gendarmerie 200 jouant ancré
dans la ruralité spécialisé mais on va
mettre des patrouilles sur les
transports urbains dans les heures de
pointe parce qu'on voit bien qu'une des
faiblesses qu'on a il y a plusieurs
régions d'ailleurs qui ont décidé de
coopérer avec nous sur ce sujet mais
c'est pas la compétence des régions
normalement c'est la compétence de
l'État et donc on doit mettre des
patrouilles spécialisés qui vont aller
pas que sur ça d'ailleurs mais le
harcèlement des jeunes filles il est
très souvent aux heures de pointe dans
les transports c'est à ce même moment là
qu'on a d'abord parfois au-delà du
harcèlement des agressions sexuelles
littéralement c'est là qu'on a du stup
et des trafics et donc c'est une un
point très important donc ça c'est les
trois réponses que je veux faire
information triplement et des forces de
police spécialisées pour pour ces
policiers comment ils peuvent aller
beaucoup plus vite hein c'est pour ça
que je les équiper en caméra quand on
peut en flagrant délit filmé parce qu'on
est équipé ça va beaucoup plus vite 2 on
a mis tous les policiers par avec une
caméra c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire on est en train de le déployer et
ça c'est une révolution et honnêtement
on s'inspire des copains on est très en
retard là dessus mais c'est un énorme
chose pour lutter contre les problèmes
de déontologie les problèmes de respect
et vous simplifier les procédures
deuxième sujet la numérisation des
procédures les feuilles comme ça
pourquoi c'est dissuasif aujourd'hui
parce que les procédures sont archaïques
nos policiers perdent un temps fou en
geste administratif on fait deux choses
on numérique Emmanuel et on développe un
corps auprès des policiers qui se qui se
qui gère
certaine manière vous demandez aux
femmes d'aller porter plainte et je veux
plus de policiers présents alors côté
dans les moments qui sont les plus
identiques c'est pas facile pour ces
femmes qui doivent aller faire une
démarche après avoir été harcelé je veux
que soit bien entendu et oui mais alors
d'accord de change de camp mais
justement allant de l'autre côté dans le
camp des garçons et ce qu'on doit pas
uniquement vous êtes sur un volet très
répressif parce qu'évidemment il y a une
urgence
est-ce que vous travaillez là-dessus
parce que quand on a des garçons des
adolescents c'est aussi le travail de
l'école des parents de travailler pour
éviter que nos enfants deviennent des
harceleurs de rue qu'est-ce qu'on fait
vous avez totalement raison d'abord hein
c'est le travail de la famille donc
c'est un travail de culturel et je pense
qu'on a tous un travail dans nos
familles et pas à travers aussi les
échanges qu'on a là de d'expliquer que
les parents ont ce rôle qui est pas
simplement d'instruire mais en effet
d'apprendre les règles et face à des
comportements
[Musique]
qui peuvent conduire à du harcèlement
d'avoir aucune tolérance je pensais la
tolérance zéro il faut l'expliquer et
quand on le voit déjà en famille ou
quand on le détecte quand on est entre
jeunes etc il faut tout de suite
expliquer avant de réprimer donc vous
avez totalement raison hein c'est le
travail de la famille deux c'est à
l'école et cette école de la confiance
et de la bienveillance à laquelle je
suis attaché qu'on veut faire c'est
aussi pour ça que je vais mettre plus de
moyens c'est évidemment une école qui
qui apprend qui apprend le savoir
fondamentaux mais qui apprend le
savoir-être et qui apprend à vivre
ensemble et donc justement et donc c'est
une école dans laquelle dès le plus
jeune âge on doit expliquer aux jeunes
garçons et aux jeunes filles le respect
de l'autre des différences et et le
respect
consiste à débat justement à une
question sur ce sujet on va l'écouter
tout de suite ensemble
à l'idée que les questions d'orientation
sexuelle et d'identité de genre soit
traitée au sein de l'école de la
République et si oui à quel âge
je ne suis pas favorable à ce que ce
soit traité dans l'école
primaire je pense que c'est beaucoup
trop tôt je suis
sceptique sur le collège mais j'ai pas
ma position n'est pas arrêtée
je suis je suis favorable mais on n'a
pas conçu faut former les enseignants
pour le faire et c'est un vrai travail
pour le faire au lycée
c'est pas très très loin de la ligne
d'Éric Zemmour je crois qu'il est contre
tout lui entre nous il est pas pour du
tout qu'on en parle à l'école on ne
voulait pas qu'on en parle pour les
petits parce que c'est pas à ce
moment-là précisément que parce que
aujourd'hui peuvent se mettre en place
et chose et les préjugés une chose et de
savoir si l'école de la République doit
vous orienter là-dessus et au fond
mettre ce sujet on parle pas de en tout
cas dans mon souvenir peut-être que je
me trompe mais en CE2 CM1 on fait pas
des cours d'éducation sexuelle
donc donc je pense que c'est en collège
qu'on commence et c'est plutôt la
deuxième partie du collège et je pense
qu'il faut d'abord faire ces cours-là et
après les questions de genre et
d'orientation
qui sont des vrais sujets sensibles il
faut avoir une parole de là aussi de
respect de bienveillance de tolérance
parce qu'il y a une immense souffrance
aujourd'hui chez nos ados
nos jeunes et des jeunes adultes et
parfois des adultes donc moi je suis
pour c'est pour ça que je suis un peu
blessé que vous me compariez à Éric
Zemmour qui a des paroles odieux sur ces
sujets moi je suis fier que dans ce
mandat on ne soit plutôt battus contre
celles et ceux qui qui justement
expliquaient
à des personnes
homosexuelles qu'il fallait faire des
thérapies de conversion nous on interdit
dans la loi bon donc moi je me bats pour
ça je suis progressiste mais je pense
que pour les enfants et les ados faut
être très prudent je suis pas sûr que ce
soit à l'école et au collège le travail
des enseignants de rentrer sur ces
sujets qui sont aussi des sujets très
délicats de formation de l'identité qui
sont des sujets
donc je veux simplement dire que 1
c'est très important qu'on en parle là
que ce soit dans le débat public de
cette campagne moi pour l'instant j'ai
jamais été interrogé là-dessus donc
merci de pouvoir en parler 2 je pense
que c'est très important qu'on ait de la
bienveillance du respect et de qu'on
accompagne tous nos ados
qui justement se posent cette question
et ont un mal-être et sont dans des
cadres où ils ont le sentiment de ne pas
être reconnu je le dis parce que on
parlait du harcèlement qui conduit à la
souffrance mais sur ces sujets beaucoup
de nos ados aussi sont une souffrance
personnelle parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment de ne pas être écoutés
accompagnés et donc c'est là aussi où je
pense que l'accompagnement qui est pas
forcément celui du prof mais auquel on
doit se faire ou l'école doit être
vigilante mais en parler aux parents et
ça peut se faire dans le périscolaire
mais mais on doit être à l'écoute et ça
aussi c'est le rôle de l'éducateur mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit à l'école
primaire j'en suis sûr de les collèges
moi je vous dis je sais plutôt mon
sentiment je suis sceptique mais qu'au
lycée qu'au lycée on est qu'on fasse ce
travail et qu'on puisse intégrer avec le
périscolaire la médecine scolaire et et
les enseignants et qu'on puisse penser
ce qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui j'y suis
favorable j'ai pas de réponse toute
faite mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
avance sur ce sujet parce que je vois de
plus en plus de jeunes qui se posent la
question et je
et je vois que c'est un sujet où il y a
un problème de ce que je dirais de
reconnaissance on va écouter la question
suivante de Tom assimilation intégration
c'est la sienne
comment définiriez-vous assimilation et
intégration et quel modèle
préconisez-vous pour la France un modèle
d'assimilation ou un modèle
d'intégration je vous remercie
alors intégration assimilation
l'assimilation c'est dans notre Code
civil
la loi française historiquement parle
d'assimilation qui est de dire vous vous
arrivez d'un autre pays vous voulez
devenir français et donc vous êtes
assimilé vos ancêtres deviennent les
Gaulois complètement digérés
moi je préfère le concept d'intégration
c'est à dire je ne suis pas
multiculturaliste je dis tout de suite
je ne suis pas pour qu'on agrège les
choses je suis pour un concept
d'intégration qui consiste à dire quand
on rentre dans la France en République
on épouse sa langue sa culture son
histoire ses valeurs on les épousent
totalement on prend l'engagement de les
respecter on prend l'engagement de de
mourir pour le drapeau et d'aimer
furieusement follement ce pays mais on
arrive avec son histoire et je pense que
notre République et notre pays doivent
respecter cette histoire et doivent
considérer que c'est aussi une richesse
et l'intégration c'est ça et c'est de
dire celui ou celle qui arrive doit
faire un effort et c'est lui le premier
à faire un effort parce qu'il arrive et
et qu'il veut rentrer dans un commun et
donc c'est d'apprendre une langue
d'apprendre une histoire d'apprendre des
règles et de les épouser et d'être
exemplaires dans leur respect
et qui a une exigence mais que dans le
même temps il y a un devoir
d'intégration c'est à dire une quand
vous avez fait tout ce travail vous êtes
le même citoyenne citoyen et je me fiche
de savoir d'où vous venez et
ce que vous êtes m'importe aussi et ça
n'est pas la même chose citoyenne
citoyen nous ne sommes pour autant pas
totalement les mêmes et votre culture
vos racines les langues que vous avez à
côté sont un apport à la République
c'est ça l'intégration c'est ce à quoi
je crois ce matin Marine Le Pen
considère que le voile et je la cite un
uniforme islamiste et elle veut
l'interdire dans l'espace public qu'en
pensez-vous
je pense que c'est
enfin elle nous redit qu'il allait
vraiment
les gens avaient oublié parce qu'ils
pensaient que c'était une femme qui
répondait qui avait un programme
socialiste pour le pouvoir d'achat bon
d'abord elle a un programme totalement
démagogique sur le pouvoir d'achat parce
qu'elle n'en finance pas un rotin donc
elle propose de raser gratis avec vos
impôts puisqu'en fait les taxes qu'elle
baisse vos impôts qui les paieront elle
propose des choses les unes
inconstitutionnelles les autres non
européennes dans le fait elle veut
sortir de l'Europe donc ça c'est
fondamentaux
mais du coup on avait oublié ce qu'elle
était vraiment
elle est pour
diviser le pays et sortir des millions
de femmes et d'hommes en disant vous
n'avez rien à faire chez moi
c'est pas ça la France pardon mais la
France notre nation et notre République
ça n'est pas ça la République c'est
liberté égalité fraternité aussi laïcité
c'est un principe de liberté d'exigence
je veux ici le redire très clairement
moi j'ai toujours défendu de manière si
je puis dire stricte
je crois que je défends la laïcité de
1905 celle de brillant
c'est un principe de neutralité des
services publics quand vous servez
l'État dans le service public là il n'y
a aucun signe religieux parce que l'État
est neutre
et au fond ces deux dire comme je disais
tout à l'heure citoyenne citoyen l'État
n'a rien à voir avec la religion mais il
ne la combat pas et donc vous pouvez
avoir une religion elle ne m'importe pas
ce que je vous demande c'est de
respecter les lois de la République
totalement dans les lois de la
République il y a pas d'interdiction du
voile parce qu'il y a pas d'interdiction
d'une religion et de ces signes dans les
lois de la République je vous demande de
ne pas porter le voile ou la croix ou la
kippa l'école primaire de la République
parce que ce sont des consciences à
l'école au collège au lycée parce que ce
sont des consciences que je forme mais
dans l'espace public l'espace public
n'est pas un lieu
ou la religion est interdite puisque ce
sont des citoyens libres et donc dans
l'espace public je n'ai pas à interdire
le voile parce que si Madame Le Pen
interdit le voile de par notre
Constitution elle va devoir interdire là
qui part elle va devoir interdire la
croix elle va devant interdire les
autres signes religieux et moi je
distingue donc ça c'est ça c'est je le
dis pour tous nos compatriotes qui nous
écoutent et dont la religion est
peut-être l'islam
ce que défend Madame Le Pen ça n'est pas
notre histoire ça n'est pas la
République ça n'est même pas notre
Constitution et donc interdire tous une
religion dans l'espace public ça n'est
pas la laïcité il y a une loi qui a été
faite en 2004 qui interdit les voiles le
voile intégrale pour des raisons bien
précises qui sont conformes à notre
Constitution lors du vote je l'aurais
voté parce que je considère que là c'est
un principe de c'est une provocation une
séparation complète c'est pas le voile
beaucoup de femmes beaucoup de mamans on
le voit elles l'ont choisi ce que je
veux moi je pense que les femmes
accompagné de sortie scolaires oui moi
j'ai toujours dit parce que sinon
qu'est-ce qu'elles font je suis
pragmatique elles sortent leur enfant de
l'école publique elles accompagnent plus
de sortie scolaire mais moi je pense que
je voudrais que ces femmes décident à un
moment de tomber le voile
vous savez il y a des je citerai pas qui
mais
dans une ville très attachée avec les
shish-sous-bois qui
est formidable et voilà c'est une ville
où on est plus comment est très attaché
il y a des
jeunes femmes qui arrivaient dans des
cours post-bac avec le voile personne
n'aura dit vous avez pas le droit de
venir parce que vous avez le droit
au bout de quelques mois elles tombent
d'elle-même
je suis pas contre le voile mais quand
elles font ce choix
c'est ça la République peut-être qu'elle
le remette si elle le choisissent mais
ça veut dire qu'il y a quelque chose qui
s'est passé d'une ouverture de
conscience et au fond c'est toujours
pareil comme je disais tout à l'heure
quand on stigmatise les gens il le
revendique dit à quelqu'un je suis
contre le voile parce que c'est pas bien
c'est pas la République même si même si
une femme n'est pas forcément religie
elle va le mettre en disant tu m'as
cherché
mais quand vous ouvrez que la République
est bienveillante qu'elle permet de
mettre autour de la table c'est jeunes
femmes ces femmes qui étaient là elles
ont été assez courtes elles ont vu
d'autres femmes notre garçon et un
moment ils ont fait le choix elles se
sont dit ma liberté c'est de le tomber
peut-être qu'elle choisisse ça c'est la
liberté c'est la République et donc
c'est très grave d'avoir ce débat parce
que c'est un débat qui nous fait bégayer
qui nous ralentit
ce qu'il faut combattre c'est ceux qui
détournent la religion ce que j'ai fait
dans mon discours des Mureaux puis dans
la loi pour les principes républicains
c'est de combattre ceux qui au nom d'une
religion
disent il faut il faut pas respecter les
lois de la République quand des gens
disent on sort les fillettes de l'école
publique on les met en voit l'intégrale
et on leur interdit la musique on leur
fait faire des dessins où il y a plus de
visage ça c'est non il faut les
combattre jusqu'au bout quand il y a au
nom de la religion des hommes qui disent
l'égalité famome n'en n'ont pas chez moi
et qui empêche les femmes d'accéder à
tel ou tel commerce ça c'est non
au titre de la laïcité de la République
parce que les lois de la République dans
la vie de la cité prévalent sur les lois
de la religion mais votre religion ne
m'importe pas question très rapide
est-ce que ça vous a fait mal de voir
les parents de Samuel Paty porter
plainte contre les manquements notamment
de l'éducation nationale sans vous
ciblez vous personnellement au contraire
même il considère que vous avez été très
présent non mais d'abord moi je pense
que il faut mesurer ce qu'est
ce qu'est la douleur de ses parents
ce sont des enseignants enfin je veux
dire le monsieur madame Paty ce sont des
c'est vraiment la famille républicaine
comme vous la voyez moi j'étais les
visitée chez eux à Moulins je veux dire
c'est une c'est une femme et un homme
qui ont passé leur vie à éduquer est-ce
que l'État
a failli justement il y a un procès qui
est en cours donc bon je je pense que
l'utilisation que certains ont voulu en
faire dans la période est abject
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous les
connaissez comme moi mais je veux dire
par là que ce que nous avons vécu ce
qu'ils ont vécu
est inhumain perdre un enfant c'est
inhumain mais l'atrocité de cette scène
et ce qu'ils ont vécu au cœur de l'école
ce qui vous imaginez la violence
symbolique que nous on a vécue eux l'ont
vécu dans leur chair et l'ont vécu dans
leur recherche parce que ils ont donné
leur vie à l'enseignement à des enfants
et ils ont transmis ça leur fils et donc
moi je
je veux dire on leur doit tout et donc
ils veulent la vérité comme tous les
parents et donc il y a une enquête qui
est ouverte cette enquête elle va
regarder le sujet et donc il y a plein
de qu'ils ont posé
je vais pas dire qu'elle n'est pas utile
elle est mais elle est déjà traitée par
l'enquête qui est ouverte puisque
l'enquête qui est ouverte non mais elle
est importante d'abord si elle est
importante pour eux je pense que c'est
le mien
la maman du fils de Samuel Paty n'a pas
décidé de se joindre à cette procédure
et évidemment les sujets doivent faire
partie de cette enquête donc si c'était
pas clair pour les parents qu'il fallait
regarder tout cela et qu'on regarde s'il
avait bien été protégé si l'éducation
nationale l'avait bien protégé si la
police avait tout de suite réagi
évidemment tout ça sera regardé et donc
voilà donc moi je rassurais tout le
monde il faut que tout ça soit regardé
avec toutes les responsabilités soient
édifiées mais enfin soyons clairs ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il y a eu et je le
dis parce qu'on est pas sur les réseaux
sociaux
il y a eu à ce moment là
le complot de la bêtise de l'islamisme
de la complaisance chez certains de la
grande violence
qui s'est emballée dans les réseaux
sociaux
une jeune fille qui manifestement ne dit
pas la vérité ou la travestie un père de
famille qui est lié à des réseaux qui se
met à l'alimenter sur les réseaux
sociaux la chose qui est utilisée pour
le pire
et la mécanique terrible avec un
collègue exactement donc c'est ça ce qui
s'est passé
mon point c'est il faut que la vérité
soit faite il faut surtout qu'on
prévienne cela et qu'on soit d'une
vigilance c'est pour ça que moi ce à
quoi j'ai oublié la douleur des parents
c'est la société de vigilance et après
leur douleur est incommensurable et donc
quelques questions d'Internationales si
vous le permettez
drame terrible aujourd'hui en Ukraine la
garde
cramatork pardonnez-moi pour
l'hésitation a été prise pour cible par
l'armée russe on parle de dizaines de
civils tués des civils qui tentaient de
fuir de s'exiler de fuir le don basse
est-ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
désormais comme Joe Biden que Vladimir
Poutine est un boucher que Vladimir
Poutine est un criminel de guerre
notre réaction tout d'abord sur ce qui
s'est passé ce matin je pense qu'on a
tous été
bouleversé choqué indigné par les images
qu'on a vu à bout de chat il y a
quelques jours à cramator aujourd'hui et
on le voit on l'a vu aussi à Mario Paul
à Carti fait dans d'autres dans d'autres
malheureusement dans d'autres villes et
on le découvrira dans les jours à venir
c'est un crime contre l'humanité
en général parce que je ne parle aussi
en tant que président de la République
je serai parce que ce sont les mots de
Jean-Yves Le Drian ce soir je sais mais
moi je serai là je suis prudent il faut
les qualifier et donc c'est pas le
politique et les qualifices c'est un
juge moi ce qui m'importe c'est qu'il
n'est pas d'impunité pour personne et
pour aucun système
la guerre que la Russie a décidé de
lancer contre l'Ukraine le peuple
ukrainien en Ukraine a changé de nature
ces derniers jours
puisqu'on voit bien que ils ont
manifestement décidé de mener des
opérations contre des civils de manière
méthodique avec des scènes de viol qui
ont maintenant qui sont en train d'être
documentés
avec
des atrocités qu'ils ont ciblé des
civils et donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut
maintenant faire 1 lancer les procédures
diplomatiques pour isoler la Russie ce
que nous avons fait en réussissant à le
sortir du Conseil des droits de l'homme
a continué le travail aux Nations Unies
deux
qualifié et donc c'est pour ça que ce
que je dis c'est qu'il faut que ça soit
qualifié par des juges donc je Biden il
va trop vite
il faut que il faut aider la justice
ukrainienne à le qualifier parce que
c'est ça qui permet derrière la
signification
ce soir sur ce qu'on a pu voir ce matin
que ce sont des crimes intolérables à
l'égard de civil et qui doivent et qu'il
ne doit et qui doivent conduire à ce que
la justice passe pardonnez-moi mais si
ce sont des crimes intolérables à
l'égard de civil ça s'appelle des crimes
de guerre
ce qui est déjà différent donc
je pense que ça c'est indéniable et donc
maintenant je veux qu'on rassemble les
preuves c'est pour ça non mais c'est
pour ça te mettre très précise je pense
que mon rôle c'est d'être utile et donc
nous nous avons envoyé des gendarmes et
des magistrats en coopération pour aider
je veux pas rentrer dans les détails
parce qu'ils sont d'un sordide complet
mais à récolter les preuves les preuves
de la culpabilité de soldats russes et
l'identité de ces soldats russes nous
avons déjà nous et les services français
avec d'autres réussit à démanteler la le
mensonge des tarus qui consistait
c'est-à-dire que ça n'était pas la
Russie que nous avons les prochaines
semaines nous avons par les images pour
les prochaines satellite puis démontrer
que c'était l'armée russe quand elle
était présente donc je pense que
honnêtement vous êtes au même en prenant
le maximum de précautions que je me dois
de prendre je peux dire que ce sont des
crimes de guerre des Russes oui et donc
je veux aider les Ukrainiens à
constituer ses preuves et à juger et
nous devons aider si la justice
craignait péché pour partie à aller
devant la Cour pénale internationale
pour qu'il y ait des jugements pourquoi
je dis ça parce que les mots ne
suffisent plus je veux les criminels
leurs noms la responsabilité des
systèmes et pas d'impunité et avec qui
vous êtes peut-être régulièrement au
téléphone régulièrement il s'appelle
Vladimir Poutine est-ce que c'est encore
un interlocuteur fiable quand on voit
ces images que la fiabilité de Vladimir
Poutine je l'ai mise en cause depuis le
mois de février je lui ai d'ailleurs dit
mais donc à quoi sert de l'appeler
régulièrement d'échanger avec lui vous
êtes l'un des rares ce que c'est mon
devoir de le faire je vais vous dire
pourquoi d'abord je l'ai fait pour
essayer d'éviter la guerre ensuite je
l'ai fait pour être un des acteurs des
négociations
à chaque fois que je le fais je le
demande président zeninski à chaque fois
le président ukrainien m'a dit parler à
Poutine est important pour moi fais-le
parce que moi je ne peux pas lui parler
en direct donc je le fais en
coordination et à la demande du
président ukrainien ensuite ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que malgré toutes ces
atrocités honnêtement à titre humain ça
me pèse de lui parler
ça n'est pas agréable mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on doit préparer le moment du
cessez-le-feu et les termes qui nous
permettent et imminent non je ne pense
pas et je pense aussi que le jour
d'après est rendu
d'autant plus complexe et même quasi
impossible compte tenu de ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre sur le terrain
ça veut dire quoi le jour d'après est
impossible mais ça veut dire que comment
revivre ensemble comment avoir un cessé
le feu qui permet ensuite la fin de tout
ça quand on a ces crimes de guerre qui
sont en train de documents à la
perspective mais vous voyez je ne la
connais pas encore mais elle est chaque
jour qui passe c'est aussi pour ça que
je me suis battu ces dernières semaines
quand vous m'avez disez vous n'êtes pas
assez sur le terrain je me j'ai passé
mais des dizaines d'heures avec Vladimir
Poutine Wallonie mirzelinski mes
collègues européens a essayé même quand
la guerre était déclenchée qu'on
n'arrive pas à ce moment-là parce qu'il
rend le sujet encore plus compliqué
quand vous avez des crimes de guerre
comment pour un chef d'État comme le
président Zéline ski conclure une paix
si facilement
comment accepter qu'il n'y ait pas de
procès il va jamais l'accepter à juste
titre donc vous voyez la difficulté qui
a pour bâtir le jour d'après elle est là
c'est la responsabilité de la Russie
mais ce que je veux vous faire
comprendre c'est que la France dans ce
contexte doit absolument
réussir à construire ce qui est une
architecture de la paix le cessez le feu
les garanties il y aura des garants pour
la sécurité d'Ukraine nous avons
vocation en faire partie c'est aussi
pour ça que nous sommes sollicités et on
le fait en lien avec les Allemands avec
l'architecture de la paix est-ce qu'elle
n'est pas compliquée je vais prendre un
autre exemple on s'éloigner de l'Ukraine
on va partir en Arabie Saoudite la
France est devenue le premier client de
l'Arabie Saoudite des mêmes armes qui
peuvent se retourner contre la
population yéménite
alors fournisseur d'armes je serai
d'abord on fait très attention sur les
armes qu'on livre à l'Arabie Saoudite je
suis surpris du classement que vous me
donnez en toute sincérité je pense pas
703 millions d'euros je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup elle a beaucoup d'autres
clients en particulier de la région je
pense pas qu'on soit le premier je veux
pas dire au monde je veux pas être de
globalement de bêtises nous on a sur les
armes qu'on donne on a le vent vous avez
totalement raison vous avez raison de le
rappeler est-ce que justement quand on
donne des armes aux Ukrainiens
quand on veut prôner la paix dans le
monde oui quand on est président d'une
puissance comme la France est-ce que
c'est normal de vendre des armes dans le
monde entier dont certaines qui peuvent
se retourner dans des conflits
les armes des Russes aujourd'hui contre
les Ukrainiens qui ont défend il y a des
armement alors pas désormais militaires
mais pas chez nous sur des armes l'État
en Russie pas
des des armements qui permettent
notamment de détruire des chars
Ukrainiens oui mais quand vous regardez
les chiffres de la France et depuis
l'embarque depuis 2014 la France n'avait
quasiment plus de flux on a respecté
complètement les chiffres de 2014 sur
l'A et des autres pays là-dessus je
serai clair un on respecte toujours les
embargos 2 quand on a des partenaires et
la France est une puissance d'équilibre
on parle à tout le monde qu'on leur
livre des armes la source était en
rapport annuel du Parlement sur les
exportations d'armement oui mais sur les
chiffres mais je pense pas qu'on soit
les premiers
je crois pas qu'on soit les premiers
mais je veux pas vous je suis étonné
donc quand on s'assure donc quand on
vend on a toujours des règles et donc
par exemple Arabie Saoudite
le contrôle de la délégation
parlementaire d'ailleurs je crois la
montrer et ça passe il y a une
commission sur la responsabilité du
Premier ministre qui met des règles et
des critères ces armements sont toujours
conditionnés et quand il y a des
conflits ou qu'on met des limites on
s'assure qu'il soit respecté et
d'ailleurs pour l'Arabie Saoudite on a
cessé de livrer certains équipements à
partir du moment où il y a les gars et
donc les chanteurs
de munitions après on a livré d'autres
parce qu'on n'a pas arrêté toute
coopération de défense mais on a arrêté
les coopérations qui nous considèrent
qu'on considérait comme impossible
compte tenu la condamnation qu'on avait
sur le conflit yéménite après je vais
être très clair dans la géopolitique si
vous dites à l'Arabie Saoudite il y a
plus il y a plus aucune relation
militaire et de défense avec vous
et vous coupez de toute la région et à
ce moment-là vous laissez la place à
d'autres c'est pas simplement moi c'est
pas le sujet je ne vends pas d'armes
l'État français gagne pas tellement
d'argent avec ces sujets là mais c'est
vrai non mais c'est terminé
à ce moment-là vous donnez la place à
d'autres et vous faites une vous laissez
une recomposition géopolitique se faire
et donc moi j'assume en effet totalement
d'être un partenaire avec ces pays il y
a des règles ils savent que quand on
condamne un conflit on stoppe les choses
on le fait de manière claire on leur
interdit on met aussi des conditions
dans la livraison des matériels mais
ensuite je veux être un partenaire de
ces pays parce que je veux pas qu'il
tombe dans les bras de la Chine et je ne
veux pas qu'il tombe dans les bras de la
Russie qui était aussi un grand
partenaire on voyait ces pays convoler
avec la Russie et quelques autres ces
dernières années et je pense que c'est
important que la France soit présente
dans cette région sur le plan
diplomatique et militaire pour conclure
Emmanuel Macron quelques questions
réponses rapides s'il vous plaît parce
que le temps passe très vite le vote à
16 ans est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre
je suis je suis pour à titre personnel
mais est-ce que vous allez mettre en
place du coup ce sera pas ma priorité je
veux dire pourquoi ma priorité c'est
déjà de lutter contre l'abstention que
tous les que tous les plus de 18 ans qui
nous écoutent à voter mais on peut pas
dire chaque année on va il y a une
abstention des jeunes et dire on va
répondre à l'abstation des jeunes vous
vous rendez le vote obligatoire je l'ai
dit il y a 3 ans moi je suis plutôt
contre ça parce que j'aime pas traiter
par l'obligation la question je voudrais
convaincre toutes celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent que l'engagement politique
passe avant toute chose par le vote et
que les nouvelles générations je les
vois par les réseaux sociaux et autres
elle s'engagent énormément par les
causes
les adhésions les pétitions c'est
parfois très efficace mais on ne sait
pas l'école de la République votre
obligatoire oui ou non tout simplement
je suis pas pour je suis plutôt pour la
conviction mais peut-être qu'à un moment
faudra en arriver là mais je suis petite
personne donc ça pourrait être évoqué
durant votre quinquennat j'ai dit on va
mettre en place une commission
transpartisane pour faire évoluer les
institutions moi je voudrais plutôt
convaincre tous les jeunes si vous
voulez changer le votre pays allez voter
et aller voter pour quelques projets que
ce soit et le projet parfait qui
correspond en totalité à ce que vous
voulez n'existe pas et donc elle est
votée juste pour le projet qui est le
plus proche du vôtre mais c'est ça la
vie en société réponse très rapide sur
l'essence qu'un à 18 centimes de remise
pendant 4 mois si ça continue comme ça
vous conduisez on conduira parce qu'on
ne peut pas laisser les prix s'envoler
oui question du vote une dernière
question qui ont peut-être on a posé la
question à Jean-Luc Mélenchon on a posé
la question à Marine Le Pen en cas de
second de premier tour qui donnerait en
tête
Jean-Marie mais Marine Le Pen et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'est-ce que fait le
citoyen
et le candidat Emmanuel Macron alors moi
j'ai jamais répondu à ces questions là
ni à 5 ans et aujourd'hui je fais pas de
politique fiction
moi je me bats pour convaincre je me
bats pas contre donc je me bats pour
être le plus haut
possible au premier tour et pouvoir
défendre mes idées au second et gagner
et donc moi je fais jamais de politique
fiction j'ai toujours pris par ailleurs
mes responsabilités
que ce soit sur mon adhésion à la
République c'est une réponse à la
question tout de même ça
Blick et vive la France sont les mots de
la fin vous remercier Emmanuel
vous remercier Emmanuel Macron merci
Thomas merci merci à tous ceux qui nous
ont suivi à savoir que le replay sera
disponible comme d'habitude
c'est déjà fini campagne oblige ou bien
tendance c'est des temps un peu plus
courts évidemment mais on vous remercie
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et à
celle de la communauté brute qui a été
très nombreux à des questions je vais
vous dire je peux dire un mot oui un
autre arabe non
beaucoup de jeunes qui nous écoutent
n'ont pas été gâtés ces dernières années
entre terrorisme pandémie maintenant la
guerre et donc je disais j'ai dit à un
moment donné pendant la crise c'est pas
facile d'avoir 20 ans en 2020 en 2022
non plus en 2022 non plus je voudrais
leur dire
dans ce moment la convie je voudrais en
faire la
je pense qu'on peut y arriver faut
s'accrocher faut se battre pour des
combats on a parlé d'écologie on a parlé
de santé d'éducation mais je voudrais
quand même leur donner un peu d'espoir
parce que l'air ambiant est un peu est
un peu lourd
ça dépend pour partie de nous moi je
pense qu'on peut y arriver
l'action sera sur le terrain pour vous
donner toutes les images dans les
différents QG les réactions des
différents candidats bref tout ce qui se
passera ce sera à suivre sur brut sur
l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux encore un
grand merci à toutes et tous d'avoir
suivi ce live vous dire également vous
avez été très nombreux à poser des
questions donc un grand merci à vous et
on se retrouve donc très très vite sur
brut et encore merci à vous et moi et
Macron et à Thomas merci pour ce live à
très bientôt bonne soirée